[Musique]
bonjour à tous Il a fermement combattu
les crimes commis par le clergé contre
les mineurs ou des personnes vulnérables
appelant constamment l'église à la
conversion à la prière à la purification
c'est en ces termes ce matin que le
Vatican présente la vie et l'oeuvre de
celui qui a régné sept ans 10 mois et 9
jours du 9 19 avril 2005 au 28 février
2013 sur l'Église universelle sur
l'Église catholique apostolique et
romaine mort le 31 décembre 2022 à 9h34
et ce sont ce matin en direct vous le
voyez les adieux à ce pape ce pape si
exceptionnel par bien des aspects Benoît
XVI
le premier pape en réalité à avoir un
renoncer à sa charge c'est en tout cas
ce que disait sur ces plateaux
d'ancestaux samedi dernier l'évêque de
Nanterre Monseigneur rouget on va aller
tout de suite place Saint-Pierre à Rome
retrouver Timothée délai bonjour
Timothée comment va se passer cette
cérémonie qu'on présente comme une
cérémonie hors norme
oui bonjour Vincent bonjour à tous et
bien écoutez vous le voyez déjà c'est
sous le brouillard et bien romain que
cette cérémonie de funérailles du pape
émérite Benoît 16 devrait débuter à 9h30
vous le voyez cette coupole de la place
Saint-Pierre qui est juste derrière moi
mais qu'on peine à distinguer dans ce
brouillard romain une messe de
funérailles historique à plusieurs
titres d'abord et bien évidemment parce
que vous l'avez dit c'est la messe de
funérailles d'un défunt pape mais
également parce que c'est la première
fois dans l'air moderne de la papauté et
bien qu'un pape en exercice le pape
François va présider la messe de
funérailles et bien de son prédécesseur
le pape Benoît XVI le pape François je
le disais qu'il va présider cette messe
de funérailles qui va notamment célébrer
qui va notamment pardon prononcer une
homélie très attendue cette messe elle
sera célébrée et bien par le doyen du
Sacré Collège cardinalis le cardinal
Giovanni Batista ré ils seront également
accompagnés le pape François et le
cardinal Monseigneur heureux et bien de
120 cardinaux du monde entier de 400
évêques également qui arrivent des
quatre coins du monde de près de 4000
prêtres également et de milliers de
fidèles qui se sont rendus sur la place
Saint-Pierre ils sont plus de 160 000 à
être venus se recueillir devant la
dépouille du pape émérite Benoît XV à
l'intérieur de la basilique Saint-Pierre
depuis lundi dernier et ce matin et bien
des six heures et demie ils étaient là
certains des milliers d'entre eux
étaient là en tous les cas et bien pour
faire la queue pour essayer d'obtenir
une place et bien évidemment au plus
proche de l'hôtel ici sur la place
Saint-Pierre certains viennent de France
nous en avons croisé nous essaierons
également bien sûr et bien d'aller les
chercher pour qu'ils nous disent
quelques quelques mots voilà des
milliers de fidèles du monde entier
énormément de prélats beaucoup de
chaînes de télévision également vous
voyez peut-être des confrères à mes
côtés voilà et pour ce qui est du
programme Vincent de ce qui nous attend
à présent en tout cas ce qui est annoncé
ici du côté et bien de la salle de
presse du Saint-Siège et bien
la dépouille le cercueil du pape Benoît
XVI doit être transféré à 8h50 depuis la
basilique Saint-Pierre jusqu'à la place
Saint-Pierre où il sera exposé pour
pendant toute la durée de la messe au
pied de l'hôtel sans suivra comme pour
de coutume pour toutes les célébrations
pontificales un chapelet récité par les
fidèles et puis le début de cette messe
de funérailles qui est donc attendu
prévu ici pour 9h30 et on voit en direct
pendant que vous parliez justement le
dépôt on a assisté au dépôt du cercueil
avec le dépôt dessus en étant en train
de le vivre en direct de
je crois que c'est un évangélique qui
est sur le cercueil du pape Benoît XVI
et on vient de voir jean-sébia bonjour
quelqu'un qui a compté beaucoup dans la
vie de Benoît XVI son secrétaire celui
qui a été longtemps son secrétaire
particulier Monseigneur gunsheim bonjour
jean-sébé bonjour
historien et journaliste vous êtes
notamment entre autres l'auteur de la
France catholique c'est aux éditions
Michel Lafont face à vous Bruno Joubert
bonjour Monsieur l'Ambassadeur bonjour
vous avez été ambassadeur de France près
le Saint Siège à la fin du pontificat de
Benoît XVI 2012 à 2015 on va y revenir
avec vous et on va revenir notamment sur
cette journée du 11 février 2013 jour de
la renonciation et puis Camille Lalan
berboutique jeune mère de famille mais
surtout emblématique représentante de la
fameuse génération Benoît XVI on ira
aussi à Vienne en Autriche retrouver le
père Clément Imbert qui lui a traduit la
biographie de Benoît XV signé du
journaliste allemand Peter zivald qui a
été celui qui a également recueilli tout
au long de son pontificat et après la
renonciation les confidences de Benoît
XVI bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
vous pouvez réagir bien entendu en
direct sur les chats le site du Figaro
et également sur le la page Youtube du
Figaro je salue notamment sitoga qui
nous dit repose en paix Saint-Père vous
partagez effectivement vos témoignages
vos souvenirs et surtout vous posez vos
questions et vous partagez vos
commentaires une première question
d'abord je vais commencer par vous Bruno
Schubert vous étiez donc en poste le 11
février 2013 jour de l'annonce de la
renonciation
comment ça s'est passé à l'ambassade ce
jour-là un ambassade nous avons comme
tout le monde
était extrêmement surpris par un
événement que personne vraiment
n'anticipait
il a fallu un peu de temps c'est à dire
une demi-heure peut-être pour s'assurer
de ce que l'on entendait de ses propos
que le pape avait tenu en latin
bref vérifiez un événement qui
paraissait tellement plein de
conséquences mais tellement
rare au point que vraiment nous nous
sommes interrogés avant d'envoyer à
Paris quelques éléments plus précis sur
ce qui était en train de se passer donc
vraiment un souvenir de quelque chose
qui est une surprise un coup de tonnerre
et un brouillard parce que lorsque les
cardinaux se réunissent en
consistoire ordinaire
bon ce qu'on appelle
or ça arrive pour certaines
circonstances assez je veux dire assez
régulièrement et
diplomatiquement on n'a pas on n'a pas
l'habitude d'y accorder trop
d'importance parce que véritablement il
ne s'y passe pas de choses qui méritent
le plus souvent d'être rapporté et là en
effet c'était le c'était le coup de
tonnerre le Pape a fait vraiment bien
préparé son et si vous me permettez une
remarque il y a une personne et ça je
tiens à le dire ici on en a parlé qu'il
y a quelques jours peut-être dans votre
dans le Figaro il y a une personne qui 4
jours avant m'a dit il se passe quelque
chose
c'était mon ancien patron Michel Barnier
que j'ai eu comme ministre des Affaires
européenne j'étais le chef le directeur
de cabinet il est venu pour une
célébration vous avez organisé autour du
la quantième anniversaire du traité de
l'Élysée et entre la France et
l'Allemagne il était venu faire une
grande conférence avec une personnalité
poétique allemande et il a eu une
audience avec le Saint Père et en
sortant de l'audience il a dit devant
moi
nous a interrogé mais cet homme est très
fatigué ne pensez-vous pas qu'il va
renoncer
alors évidemment nous avons tous dit
mais non vraiment est-ce possible
les sottises qu'on peut dire parfois
dans ces cas-là en tout cas le manque
d'imagination certainement et infinie je
rends hommage à la sagacité
de Michel Barnier dans ce domaine dans
ce domaine quel est le souvenir que vous
gardez de Benoît XV
celui
oserais-je dire
d'une forme d'affection
que je lui ai porté de la minute où je
l'ai rencontré pour lui remettre mes
lettres de créance nous avons eu une
conversation comme les ambassadeurs en
ont une à ce moment-là qui a duré 25
minutes peut-être
et je suis sorti ébranlé ému
de cet entretien et du coup j'ai eu le
sentiment de nouer avec cet homme que
pratiquement plus revu depuis ensuite
pour des entretiens de ce type
un lien affectif très profond nous
étions dans ces cas-là l'ambassadeur
vient avec sa famille ma famille il a
été présentée j'avais une petite fille
qui la bénie donc tout ça m'a laissé un
sentiment de très grande
curieusement affection et évidemment un
immense respect pour cet homme
ce regard cette parole ce Français
merveilleux qu'il parlait mieux que moi
enfin vraiment
très très émouvant quel est le souvenir
que vous gardez aujourd'hui de Benoît
XVI Jean Célia alors je suis pas là pour
parler de moi mais un tout petit sourire
personnel il se trouve que j'ai eu la
chance pour le figure malaisien
interviewer Joseph atseinger était en
2001 et donc j'avais eu une heure
Vatican avec lui en tête-à-tête pour moi
c'est un des grands moments de ma future
journaliste qui reste un souvenir très
très chaud et très émouvant
j'avais l'impression d'être un homme
fascinant de gentillesse de douceur avec
un tel contraste avec cette fameuse
formule du panzerkane
bienveillant puis d'une intelligence
lumineuse j'ai pas besoin de le dire un
français parfait
moi j'étais ébloui éblouie et j'en ai
ressenti comme assurance de grande
grande affection pour cet homme grande
affection qui n'était pas crois pas que
je savais pas qu'il serait papa jour
mais c'est quelque chose de très
frappant voilà alors par ailleurs comme
comme je moi c'est pas le pas de ma
jeunesse ça a été Jean-Paul II donc
c'était déjà le pape de ma maturité
Benoît XVI j'ai observé avec un intérêt
constant l'effort qu'il a entrepris pour
peut suivre une oeuvre difficile en
permanence sous la mitraille voilà c'est
un homme incompris il aurait été à papa
compris je crois qu'ils sont venait pas
d'être pape et son patricia a été un
planificat de combat
et je pense que ça renonciation
s'explique aussi comme ça c'est un homme
qui avait été usé par le combat qu'il
avait mené il est considéré que il n'est
plus en mesure de poursuivre sa tâche
tellement il était fatiguée on va y
revenir tout au long de cette cérémonie
9h30 c'est l'heure prévue pour le début
de cette messe donc qui sera célébrée
par le doyen du Sacré
le cardinal Giovanni Batista arrêt et
présider par le pape François Camille
Lalan berduti vous n'est pas le pape de
la votre maturité parce que vous n'avez
pas encore atteint ce stade dans tous
les cas sur un maturité intellectuel
sans doute mais on regarde votre état
civil pas encore quel souvenir d'abord
le plus immédiat le plus fort vous
gardez le bonheur
je crois que c'était JMJ de Madrid où
j'accompagne un groupe de gmjistes d'une
paroisse de région parisienne
et c'est on en a beaucoup parlé c'est
une image qui est restée le samedi soir
nous sommes 2 millions de personnes
sur l'aéroport de quattrovientos pour la
vallée d'adoration et il a fait une
chaleur de de beuh toute la journée il y
avait plus de 40 degrés et tout d'un
coup le soir arrive donc cette ville
d'adoration arrive le ciel se couvre et
tout d'un coup
au moment des échanges entre des jeunes
qui posaient des questions aux Saint
Père et la réponse de Saint Père il y a
une espèce de de tornade qui s'abattent
sur sur l'aéroport et sur nous tous et
c'est un peu la panique à bord tous en
vol il y a en même temps une espèce de
joie qui reste et voilà et là-dedans au
milieu de tout ça c'est le pape qui
reste assis à sa place pas du tout
déconcentré pas du tout décontenancé
sous cette grande estrade blanche sous
un espèce de d'arbres jaune lumineux il
reste avec nous dans la dans la
tourmente dans la tornade protégée par
des par des parapluies et on se disait
c'est super on a un peuple qui reste
avec nous et qui partage ce moment il y
a sa culotte qui s'envole il y a ses
cheveux qui s'envolent il finit à moitié
bouriffé
et je trouvais ça hyper hyper touchant
ça le rendait proche de nous donc c'est
un beau moment ce qui est vrai c'est que
c'est un scène qui est qui a beaucoup
marqué et peut-être on y reviendra parce
que c'est une scène qui contraste
précisément avec avec sa renonciation je
voudrais qu'on aille à Vienne où se
trouve le père Clément Imbert bonjour
mon père
vous êtes français vous êtes en poste en
Autriche vous occupez notamment des
communautés françaises qui sont là-bas
vous avez traduit la biographie de
Benoît XVI
revenir d'abord vous personnellement
quel souvenir vous gardez de Benoît XVI
excusez-moi petite extinction de voix ce
matin le
je n'ai malheureusement comme beaucoup
de personnes du plateau pas eu
l'occasion de rencontrer personnellement
c'est donc un souvenir plutôt au sein
d'un gros d'une communauté lors de une
grande liturgie moi j'ai un souvenir
extrêmement
ému des obsèques de de Saint Jean-Paul
II qu'il a qu'il a en tant que doyen des
cardinaux célébrés de revoir
spécialement les images que nous avons
devant les yeux en ce moment me rappelle
bien entendu ce moment où d'une certaine
façon
Joseph ratinger qui qui était quand même
connu du public sort malgré tout un peu
de l'ombre malgré lui puisque c'est là
je veux qu'il préside cette célébration
mais
on a le sentiment effectivement d'avoir
quelqu'un qui qui était là pendant tout
ce temps qui était au service et aux
côtés de Jean-Paul II et qui nous qui
nous aide d'une certaine façon à mesurer
la perte du grand pape mais à comprendre
aussi que que l'Église
l'église tient bon et d'une certaine
façon beaucoup de personnes ont
pressenti lors de cette célébration que
voilà que Joseph Ratzinger n'avait pas
fini
justement cette
ce moment de la vie de Ratzinger figure
bien évidemment au cœur de la biographie
du consacre Peter zivald vous l'avez
traduite
qu'est-ce que ce livre révèle et
qu'est-ce qu'il vous a révélé sur Benoît
XVI
la première chose que ce livre révèle
c'est le une grande unité de vie chez
cet homme qui est passé par beaucoup de
choses beaucoup d'étapes enfin comme
chacun d'entre nous surtout lorsque l'on
a vécu 95 ans qui est né dans la Bavière
encore profondément en catholique qui
très jeune déjà doit affronter le
nazisme puis la guerre la reconstruction
des années pas très simple ensuite le
conseiller l'expérience extrêmement
enivrant et belle et puis et puis en
même temps cette grande révolution
sociale à laquelle nous assistons
mais en fait à travers toutes ces étapes
on pressant quelque chose de
profondément unifié quelque chose de
j'allais dire presque de stable une
espèce de souveraineté qui est liée à
tout simplement à la fois d'un homme qui
tout en étant un grand intellectuel
et toujours tourner vers Dieu et donc
avec l'intelligence qui est la ciel la
curiosité intellectuelle qui est la
sienne
fait preuve et dégâts une voilà une
sérénité une stabilité une unité
intérieure qui en fait fait un bien fou
à toutes les personnes qui sont sur son
chemin et c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui m'a particulièrement marqué
émue de découvrir cela parce que cela
correspondait profondément à ce que
j'avais moi-même disons expérimenté en
lisant ces textes en le découvrant comme
paps se fait aussi partie de cette
génération Benoît XVI de voir que tout
cela remonte à très loin en fait à la
fois de son enfance à l'éducation qu'il
a reçu à la formation et on rencontre
tout au long de son parcours voilà une
grande unité
c'est quoi la génération Benoît XVI pour
les prêtres
alors moi c'est vraiment le calendrier
qui qui me permet de dire cela puisque
j'ai commencé mon séminaire en
2004 automne 2004 et donc j'ai assisté
disons mes premières expériences
spirituelles de séminariste ont été
justement
l'agonie de Jean-Paul II le les obsèques
le Conclave et puis la nomination de
Benoît XV avec cette ce cadeau de la
Providence puisque Benoît XVI se
retrouve quelques mois après son sa
nomination comme pape donc Journée
Mondiale de la Jeunesse sa colonne donc
il retourne sur ces terres j'ai vécu
tout cela très près j'ai vécu bien sûr
la la sortie des premières encycliques
quand on est jeune séminariste on est
bien sûr assoiffé de tout ce qui peut
venir du pape et du Vatican et donc j'ai
vraiment eu le sentiment d'être d'avoir
reçu les grandes empreintes spirituelles
et théologiques de ma formation au
sacerdos à travers ces textes à travers
ces catéchèses à travers au front toutes
les toutes les prises de position
publique du pape y compris celle qu'il a
qu'il a fait en France qui ont été pour
beaucoup d'entre nous extrêmement
marquantes
merci beaucoup pour ces premières
réponses et première précision père
Clément Humbert on va revenir bien
entendu avec vous tout au long en tout
cas au début de cette cérémonie pour
justement que vous nous expliquiez
également
ceux qui se passe ce que l'on voit ce à
quoi on assiste j'en sais via je reviens
vers vous on vient de voir d'ailleurs le
président italien Sergio martinella il
m'a semblé Bruno Joubert et également la
première ministre la présidente du
Conseil italien le Georgia mélony
qui sont donc arrivés qui font partie
des délégations officielles on va
revenir justement sur cette question des
délégations officielles parce que là
aussi Bruno Joubert il y a un protocole
un peu particulier vous allez peut-être
nous éclairer sur ce point peut-être pas
sans doute Jean une question vous signez
vous avez signé un grand article dans Le
figa de lundi dans l'édition papier de
figure de lundi sur l'apport théologique
fondamentale et énorme de Benoît XVI
est-ce que quand vous entendez le père
Humbert
c'est à cette lumière là que vous dites
que l'apport a été a été conséquent oui
pour moi c'est c'est
on enverra peut-être mais tout le débat
sur la la renonciation je dirais mérite
un petit peu parce qu'il
occulte l'essentiel de l'oeuvre de José
et même son point de figure c'est s'il
s'appellent était mort de mort naturelle
une crise cardiaque deux jours avant son
association il y aurait pas ce débat sur
la prononciation donc pour moi c'est un
des grands intellectuels de l'Église
catholique au 20e siècle son apport une
soixantaine de livres des une théologie
fondamentale
certains livres facils à lire d'autres
plus plus complexes faut pas ça c'est
pas comme une bande dessinée bon mais
c'est un apport essentiel
de Jean-Paul II c'est clair aussi parce
que
le cardiaque était un soutien
intellectuel du pape Jean-Paul II et
donc pour moi c'est un apport qui est
tout à fait massif et ça s'arrête dans
le jeu de clergé ça reste dans les
nouvelles générations de cap des
catholiques les plus engagés c'est pour
ça que quel que soit
certaines prudence que l'on voit parfois
chez certains
chers certaines sommité ecclésiastiques
et je ne parle même pas des semi-tesses
à l'égard de l'Ouest parce que il y a
toujours une certaine mauvaise
réputation auxquelles certains sont
sensibles je crois que ça c'est pas
important je veux dire il y a un apport
fondamental de Benoît XV de Red Singer
qui va rester dans l'église et c'est sur
cette base là que vont se construire
beaucoup de choses dans l'avenir de
l'église on va retourner à Rome où se
trouve nos envies spéciaux
Timothée délène et Jean-Marie Guennois
dans une petite minute maintenant
Camille l'homme verduti on a entendu
justement ce que a apporté à ce à ce
prêtre le pontificat de Benoît XV qui en
gros a été le pontificat de son
séminaire le pontificat de sa formation
on voit la famille royale de Belgique et
la reine Sophie la reine Sophie
d'Espagne
le qui sont arrivés
pour vous qu'est-ce que ça a apporté
est-ce que l'apport il est spirituel
l'apport il est intellectuel est-ce que
l'apport il est humain
dans un premier temps c'est d'abord un
apport humain on reçoit un pape et alors
c'est peut-être la différence de
génération qui fait ça mais chaque pas
moi je le reçois comme un grand-père
j'ai entendu parler tout à l'heure de
d'affection et c'est vraiment ça qu'on
ressent à chaque fois pour ces pour ses
papes qui nous sont donnés on a
l'impression de l'accueillir dans la
famille il y a une vraie une vraie
relation oui d'affection qui se qui se
crée en verse pas pourtant c'est pas
justement quelque chose qu'on se disait
concernant le pape le pape Benoît XVI
c'est d'abord il y avait mauvaise
réputation comme le dit j'en sais villa
et en plus quand même c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est dans les fusions mais
non mais en fait
moi je trouve que par exemple
Jean-Paul II pour moi c'était le
grand-père mais le grand-père très
affectueux on avait envie de de se
blottir dans ses bras et de d'aller
demander
d'être consolé par lui Benoit Saez pour
moi c'est le grand-père sage c'est la
personne de sagesse qui on a on aurait
envie d'aller évoquer ces difficultés
ces grandes questions dans la vie dont
on sait que il nous écoutera et il nous
répondra avec avec parcimonie et avec
justesse donc en fait pour moi c'est cet
apport est d'abord c'est d'abord un
apport humain et ensuite dans un
deuxième temps on rentre un petit peu
plus dans ces dans ces textes
dans ces différents livres dans ces
différentes dans ces différents
enseignements et du coup ça devient
ensuite un enseignement plutôt logique
et j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'il
allait chercher à nous mener à Dieu
à nous donner Dieu et à nous mener à
Dieu dans les deux sens
pour vous quel a été
l'apport de Benoît XVI je vous pose
cette question parce que
on voit bien qu'elle a été l'apport au
plan diplomatique de Jean-Paul II le
tombeur du communisme on voit bien
l'activisme du pape du pape François
notamment bien sûr sur la question
migratoire mais également parfois se
sortir à l'emporte-pièce pas très
diplomatique sur les sur les conflits en
cours par contre on a un petit peu plus
de mal avec Benoît XVI
une première marche je pense que
mais deux autres interrupteurs l'ont dit
Benoît XV c'est d'abord impact
théologien c'est d'abord une grande
figure
ecclésiale religieusement morale aussi
et de ce point de vue il s'inscrit à la
fois dans la
transition vers autre chose mais aussi
dans la tradition puisqu'il a été en
effet auprès de Jean-Paul II la tête de
la
duicester pour d'adopter de la foi donc
il a au fond piloter ça ça c'est le
premier point alors si on passe sur le
plan politique en effet le plan
politique et diplomatique là le bilan
force est de le constater
malheureusement
n'est pas aussi éloquent que celui de
son prédécesseur à l'évidence et
peut-être que celui de son successeur il
est trop tôt pour le dire
je crois que Benoît XVI avait
des principes très clairs sur ce qu'il
voulait en matière diplomatique il a
exprimé par exemple au moment de la
crise de Syrie où là il voulait à la
fois que l'on soit qu'on rompt pas avec
aucun des participants pour continuer un
dialogue évitez les fusions de sang et
apporter de l'aide de ce point de vue il
était un petit peu en décalage avec bien
des puissances de l'époque de dans notre
pays non là dans la France ensuite je
crois qu'il a eu une action qui est
moins diplomatique au sens des états
qu'une action diplomatique au sens de
diplomatie ecclésiale il a beaucoup fait
pour par exemple la question de de le
cuminisme il a retrouvé le chemin d'une
discussion sérieuse et franche avec les
orthodoxes et notamment avec Moscou il a
fait cette visite à Chypre cette visite
en Turquie la visite auprès du
patriarche humanique Constantinople donc
il a su la renouer des liens que la
personne même de Jean-Paul II avait
contribué à attendre par le fait que on
sait bien comment tout cela c'est été
noué autour de Jean-Paul de le troisième
élément c'est évidemment
dans cette domaine là la question de la
relation avec l'Islam alors on en fait
souvent une question de querelle on dira
thisbonne on va revenir un petit peu
c'est un aspect important aussi de
l'action sur l'affaire de je voudrais
qu'on aille justement on retourne place
Saint-Pierre sous la brume retrouver
sous cette brume on les voit Timothée
d'Hélène et Jean-Marie gaynouard
Timothée c'est à vous
oui Vincent avec Jean-Marie Guaino à que
vous connaissez bien du Figaro
spécialiste des questions religieuses
bonjour Jean-Marie bonjour Timothée un
mot sur ce qu'il est en train de se
passer actuellement on a un quart
d'heure du début de la messe là c'est la
fin du chapelet c'est ça voilà donc le
corps le cercueil plutôt a été
transporté tout à l'heure à 8 8h50 par
12 hommes qui l'ont pris donc devant le
l'hôtel de la basilique Saint-Pierre et
puis ils ont remonté la nef ils sont
sortis très solennellement l'ont déposé
à même le sol va sur un tapis mais à
même le sol et puis à ce moment là les
fidèles présents et il y a donc
évidemment les cardinaux des évêques des
prêtres des fidèles ont commencé la
prière du Rosaire la prière sainte
prière à Marie ou une méditation des de
la vie du Christ à travers des notre
père des jeux où c'est le mari qui sont
récités et donc c'est la préparation
spirituelle de de ce moment de cette
messe d'obsèques et dans quelques
minutes apparaîtra le pape enfin le
laisser les qui vont arriver en
procession pour commencer la messe
proprement dit des obsèques Vous avez
avec vous le livret de cette messe un
mot déjà sur la couverture du livret
c'est un célèbre tableau du Caravage
rien que ça oui ben le Caravage est très
expressif on voit une déposition de la
Croix peut-être le montrer à l'écran
c'est un tableau d'ailleurs le pas
François apprécie beaucoup le Caravage
peut-être est-il à l'origine de ce choix
ce livret de Metz donc comme pour toutes
les célébrations les grandes
célébrations ici à Rome et au Vatican le
Vatican imprime un livret de Metz avec
les lectures on va tout le dérouler les
prières parce qu'il y a toutes les
langues quasiment du latin de l'allemand
de l'anglais de l'espagnol du français
de l'italien évidemment justement
Jean-Marie comment va se dérouler cette
messe par exemple en quelle langue
est-ce que les différentes lectures vont
être prononcées par exemple la première
lecture va être lu en espagnol il y aura
il y aura ensuite je vois se mettant
latin il y a la deuxième lecture en
anglais et puis l'Évangile en
italien pour les non initiés en fait la
première partie de la messe reprend en
fait une partie où on lit des textes de
la Bible toujours un texte de l'Ancien
Testament donc avant l'arrivée du Christ
en général la première lecture puis un
texte de des épitres de Paul
c'est-à-dire qui ont été écrites par
saint Paul après le Christ et puis
l'Évangile dans proprement un extrait
des quatre évangiles qui racontent la
vie du Christ c'est tout à fait
structuré dans la liturgie catholique et
les textes ont été choisis évidemment en
fonction de de la circonstance ce ne
sont pas des textes habituellement pris
pour des obsèques d'un pape premiums qui
ont été choisis à dessin on va les
découvrir tout à l'heure et c'est la
première partie de cette messe
d'obsèques est-ce que ça veut dire que
le Pablo ne cesse a droit entre
guillemets à une messe de funérailles
d'un pape sachant qu'il était émérite
est-ce qu'il y a une différence par
rapport par exemple à la messe de
funérailles du pape Jean-Paul II les
différences sont vraiment minimes il y a
une différence sur le plan des prières à
la fin de la messe il y a une série de
prière au moment où le corps va partir
pour être enterré dans une des cryptes
de du Vatican d'ailleurs là où Jean 23
et Jean-Paul II ont été enterré un
moment donné donc c'est au premier
sous-sol de la basilique et il y avait
des prières adaptées au pape qui venait
qui vient de décéder c'est c'est la
coutume évidemment catholique dans ce
cas là c'est prière ont été retirées
d'autres prières plus simples seront
prononcées on peut pas qualifier de la
différence de grandes différences en
fait regardez ce qui se passe regardez
cette place Saint-Pierre cette basilique
le cercueil est là vraiment au milieu de
tous le pape est présent enfin c'est
quand même il y a des chefs d'État il y
a des rois des reines c'est quelque
chose de de de d'imposants enfin de à la
fois sobre et en même temps solennelle
et on peut pas dire que il y a une sorte
de d'obsèques ou de funérailles au
rabais pas du tout vraiment Benoît XV et
honoré comme pape émérite avec des
différences qui sont de l'ordre du
détail un mot Jean-Marie guenois sur
évidemment cet homélie du pape François
qui est un moment très attendu ici par
les fidèles présents sur la place
Saint-Pierre mais également dans le
monde entier est-ce que l'on a une idée
et bien de ce que va dire le pape
François alors je le sais je devrais pas
vous le dire parce qu'effectivement on a
le texte un peu avant je peux dire que
c'est une nuit très courte comme M le
les prononcer le pape François c'est
n'aime pas les obliger interminables
elle est très c'est une sorte de
méditation sur finalement le
l'État le l'état de pasteur celui qui
conduit un troupeau avec des citations
de Benoît XVI un texte très très profond
un texte de
très émouvante sur ce qu'a été Benoît
XVI qui est une sorte de portrait
spirituel du pape de Benoît XV vu par
son successeur un dernier mot Jean-Marie
guesnoy serait bien et on a parlé
beaucoup des fidèles présents les
officiels également que ça soit du côté
français mais également des membres de
différentes confessions chrétiennes qui
sont présentes on sait que cette unité
des chrétiens c'était également un thème
très qui tenait auquel le pape Benoît
XVI tenait beaucoup alors il y a 23
représentants exactement de confessions
chrétienne on dit on dit pas des
religions chrétiennes on a des
confessions c'est-à-dire
tous partagent la même fois chrétienne
mais la confesse de manière différente
donc c'est la même religion chrétienne
dont le catholicisme alors il y a
évidemment dans leur historique les
églises
orthodoxes qui sont en primauté à
égalité en quelque sorte avec l'Église
catholique puisque elles sont nées au
même moment c'est tout ça c'est le
premier millénaire jusqu'en 1054 10
c'est une rupture avec l'orthodoxie puis
arrive la réforme et là il y a toute la
branche
des protestante très formés avec toute
la galaxie restante les anglicans qui
sont un cas un peu à part aussi
donc on a là toute la gamme possible du
christianisme dans toutes ces
déclinaisons dans toutes ces
sensibilités sous toutes ses attitudes
parce que le christianisme n'est pas
forcément
occidental il est d'abord oriental il
est d'abord il est né à Jérusalem
fondamentalement le berceau est là et là
ce matin on a des représentants de
toutes ces confessions chrétiennes qui
viennent honorer ce qu'il reconnaisse
comme soit le pape de Rome soit l'évêque
de Rome sur le chef de l'Église
catholique en tout cas comme un frère un
frère qui est qui est un frère
catholique mais qui est séparé mais qui
est néanmoins frère et qui attend dans
tous les cas le début de cette messe de
funérailles merci beaucoup Jean-Marie
Guaino alors que le pape François
[Musique]
oui alors je n'ai pas les détails de
l'organisation est-ce qu'il va revêtir
une chaise dans quelques instants ça me
paraîtrait avoir bah c'est pas lui
célébrant de la messe bien entendu enfin
quand même en effet c'est un patient est
un petit peu minimal mais je n'ai pas
les détails ce qui est en tous les cas
plus frappant peut-être Bruno Joubert
c'est si cette image quand même du pape
du pape François qui arrive et qui est
quand même lui-même
avec une santé qui est quand même pas
optimale et là on revient vers ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la
démission et l'ombre portée sur le règne
de Benoît XVI commence à sourdre des
questions sur le thème mais après tout
si le pape est en effet comme on le voit
maintenant un peu en difficulté sur le
plan physique
quelles sont les conséquences qui
pourraient légitimement maintenant en
être sinon tiré du moins inspiré et je
crois que lorsqu'on voit le Saint-Père
ainsi dans cette chaise on a à la fois
l'image de Jean-Paul II vieillissant et
malade donc cet aspect-là des choses de
la souffrance de celui qui endure et
puis on a désormais aussi cette
ouverture un peu particulière qui est
celle que Benoît XVI a franchi on va
essayer de retrouver le père Humbert à
Vienne est-ce que on est en direct avec
lui oui le voilà père Clément Humbert on
vient de voir donc le pape donc François
arrivé également derrière la procession
est-ce que vous pouvez justement nous
expliquer un petit peu ce que l'on est
en train de voir
effectivement puisque le pape François
n'est pas en tenue liturgique et il est
entré
séparément effectivement le la question
de Jean Sevilla se pose n'est pas je
n'ai pas de réponse j'imagine
effectivement que compte tenu du fait
que on a encore jamais vu un pape
présidé les obsèques de d'un pape il a
été prévu il a été convenu que que les
choses se dérouleraient un peu
différemment est-ce que est-ce que le
pape François va revêtir une tenue
liturgique nous découvrirons mais
effectivement il n'était donc pas
directement dans la dans la procession
que nous venons de voir où semble-t-il
se sont avancés les d'abord les tous les
savants de messe les diacres et puis
ensuite les il me semble que ce sont les
cardinaux voilà nous voyons maintenant à
l'image que le que le pape François a
été revêtu d'une chape et effectivement
cela indique qu'il n'est qu'il n'est pas
là en tant que con célébrant
il a une tenue liturgique certainement
lui qui aura participé passion je pense
pour l'homélie mais il n'est pas
effectivement dans le dans le cortège
que nous avons vu s'avancer ou était les
cardinaux avec le célèbre principal le
cardinal ré
une question d'habitude pour des
funérailles il me semble les célébrans
sont en violet or là ils sont en rouge
oui
pour être raisonnable je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas l'expérience suffisante je
me souviens effectivement que pour les
pour les obsèques de Jean-Paul II il en
était ainsi
cela doit certainement indiquer une une
tradition selon lequel le pape lorsque
nous participons participer aux obsèques
du pape alors c'est le c'est la couleur
qui convient c'est aussi la couleur que
nous utilisons lorsque nous célébrons
les saints apôtres peut-être que cette
peut-être que c'est traditions sont
liées l'une à l'autre peut-être que
quelqu'un pourrait compléter mon propos
on va peut-être demander Bruno Joubert
j'avoue n'avoir pas de réponse sur ce
jeu point je crois avoir eu que pour un
pape justement c'est en rouge mais on va
demander peut-être à nos internautes
effectivement s'ils peuvent nous
éclairer sur ce sur ce point on voit
donc la procession on va
qui va commencer dans deux minutes
maintenant laissez-vous vivre vous
laissez vivre pardon ces premières
images et ces premiers ces premiers
instants vous êtes nombreux à nous
rejoindre sur les chats et en
particulier sur Youtube et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous merci de
suivre cette cérémonie sur le site du
Figaro repose en paix Saint Père nous
dit espoir je que s'il a vécu 95 ans je
ne suis pas triste mais content il sera
accueilli au paradis comme un roi c'est
ce que vous pensez
je pense que
l'instant de la mort et l'instant de la
rencontre et de la vérité donc je pense
que c'est un moment crucial
je pense que c'est le moment où on doit
avoir un certain nombre de réponses à
des questions et je pense que c'est ça
doit être une grande joie pour ces pour
ces hommes c'est pas qui est menacé
évidemment qui ont donné leur vie au
Christ et à Dieu enfin d'arriver au bout
du chemin et de commencer cette nouvelle
vie ça va être quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire je le souhaite
un autre point
effectivement qui est frappant
aujourd'hui c'est que les précédentes
obsèques la souverain pontife avait été
célébré alors celui dont on célèbre les
obsèques aujourd'hui
c'est une force de continuité
je vois la sagacité de Jean Sévilla
et dont on va bénéficier tout au long de
cette cérémonie
par de là peut-être encore un mot avant
de de d'aller place Saint-Pierre pour le
début de cette célébration
sur la renonciation vous disiez tout à
l'heure elle occulte
l'oeuvre de Benoît XVI et est-ce qu'elle
l'occulte ou elle éclaire
moi je crains qu'il l'occupe puisque ne
l'éclair parce qu'on s'est polarisé sur
cette question
d'abord cette décision d'un homme que je
respecte l'homme les décisions
c'est pas inscrit dans les textes je
veux dire le successeur du pape François
pour elle n'a pas faire le même choix si
très âgé il est très malade il pourra
décider comme Jean-Paul II de vivre
jusqu'au bout son pontificat donc il y a
rien c'est pas quelque chose de
définitif donc n'en faisons pas un acte
du ministère du Magistère de l'Église
comme si c'était c'est pas dogmatique on
va y revenir au début de la célébration
confiture
et à vous mes frères que nous avons
péché en péché de mission
c'est notre faute max ma grande faute
c'est pourquoi je supplie la
bienheureuse
tous les Saints et vous mes frères
je vous prie de prier pour moi le
Seigneur notre Dieu
à la vie éternelle
[Musique]
donc peut-être une première indication
il y a plusieurs langues qui vont être
utilisés
au cours de cette messe nous disait tout
à l'heure Jean-Marie gesnoy mais
apparemment là ce qu'on vient d'entendre
c'est du latin
c'est généralement je précise ce point
parce que ça a été quand même un point
important du pontificat de Benoît XV de
remettre la langue liturgique de
l'Église et plus encore à la liturgie
latine est un rapport et tout à fait
intime voilà qui a même suscité
polémique par rapport à son acte par
rapport à la liturgie
préconilière mais évidemment c'est un
homme de grande culture de culture
européenne de culture
nourrites Saint-Augustin
il est par définition enfin il est le
pape du latin si je puis dire donc il
est qui est du latin pour ses obsèques
mon dieu ça me paraît tout à fait dans
l'ordre des choses
là c'est même plutôt du grec qu'on est
en train d'entendre mais juste un point
sur cette sur l'ensemble de la cérémonie
sur ce que disait tout à l'heure
Jean-Marie gaynois il y a un certain
nombre de délégation étrangères on a vu
notamment des têtes couronnées
celle du roi de Belgique en particulier
pourtant ce sont pas des délégations qui
sont invitées la France est représentée
par
Emmanuel par Gérald Darmanin
et on dit il y a deux pays qui sont
invités alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut venir
même si on n'est pas invités
il fut le président par le pape toute
chapelle papal venir qui souhaitent
un Skitch qui change ensuite c'est le
traitement protocolaire dans un cas on a
une invitation formelle d'État état si
je puis dire et il s'y attache un
certain nombre de privilèges d'honneur
lorsqu'on est invité
lorsqu'on y vient de soi-même on a droit
à des égards mais ils ne sont pas
exactement au même niveau et c'est bien
ce qu'on a voulu marquer dans cette
affaire là c'est qu'on a invité
l'Allemagne les raisons évidentes les
autres pays du pape mais les autres
viennent
j'allais dire par souci de marquer leur
déférence la qualité des liens qu'ils
ont pu avoir avec lui on voit certaines
familles royales qui sont de tradition
liées avec le catholicisme mais au
quotidien si je puis dire enfin plutôt
au moment de cette cérémonie on enverra
pas ce sont dans les nuances vous voyez
ce carré qui est à droite de l'écran sur
l'esplanade ce carré là c'est le carré
des diplomates aussi bien les
ambassadeurs en place que les invités
formels les délégations sont rangées par
ordre protocolaire il y a certainement
la délégation on l'a vu d'ailleurs
italienne allemande qui sont en bonne
position puis les autres après sont
passés
et le respect de l'ordre protocolaire du
Vatican
l'ermenottique de la continuité cette ce
que nous dit cette cette internaute qui
vient de nous rejoindre sur le site du
Figaro vous pouvez continuer de
commenter peut-être justement une une
traduction j'en Sévilla hermanétique de
la continuité c'est une référence à un
discours de Benoît XV qui a été un
discours majeur sans pontificat c'est
majeur et qui a procédé de sa vision de
la vision de l'église c'était que pour
lui toute réforme dans l'église devait
être homogène par rapport à c'est
l'Église dans l'église il y a pas de de
nouveautés en quelque sorte n'ont pas la
seule nouveauté était survenue il y a
2000 ans qui avait dit du Christ sur
terre mais toutes toutes l'oeuvre de
l'église est un approfondissement
continuité de la révélation donc il y a
pas de vrai total nouveautés dans
l'église est-ce que vous lui dire le
Benoit sai José fatinger c'est que
tout changement doit s'ordonner doit
naître
je dirais presque de manière naturelle
par rapport à un lait qui est un lac
très ancien
et donc mais c'était le même type de la
continuité de la réforme parce que c'est
un homme qui est aussi en même temps un
réformateur attention en faisant pas un
traditionnaliste pur qui n'était pas
c'était un homme de Vatican 2 qui a su
mettre totalement la théologie de
Vatican 2 et je veux dire mais s'il
voulait interpréter Facebook comme une
continuité on va revenir à ces questions
là la célébration continue on retourne à
Rome Seigneur
le potier ressemble-t-il à l'argile pour
qu'une oeuvre
ose dire à celui qui l'a fait il ne m'a
pas fait
dire à son potier
il ne sait pas travailler
l'éthique pas vrai que dans peu de temps
le Liban redeviendra un verger et le
verger fera penser à une forêt
en ce jour-là les sourds entendront les
paroles du livre et délivrée de l'ombre
et des ténèbres les cieux les aveugles
verront
[Musique]
voilà première lecture tirée du livre
d'Isaïe si le père Clément Imbert est
encore avec nous on va lui demander
peut-être une petite précision sur sur
cette sur cette première lecture tirée
du livre design
oui le
d'apporter ma petite pierre à la
question du latin moi qui est
l'expérience d'être beaucoup à
l'étranger avec des communautés de toute
langue je dois reconnaître que il y a
une dimension extrêmement pratique qui
nous explique aussi pourquoi l'Église et
de recul dans une rencontre comme
celle-là
est utilisé quelque chose aussi
extrêmement pratique
la lecture d'Isaïe nous parle de cette
belle image qui me fait d'ailleurs
beaucoup penser à plusieurs propos du
pape Benoît à savoir l'instrument entre
les mains du potier c'est une c'est une
image que l'on peut que l'on entend
souvent
qui en tout cas touche beaucoup les
fidèles
parce que c'est un geste qui est qui est
un geste extrêmement tendre et qui
montre effectivement cette dimension de
se laisser façonner par la grâce de Dieu
et c'est vrai que c'était quelque chose
qui était qui était très cher à au pape
Benoît si vous vous souvenez il a il a
parlé du serviteur de l'art le serviteur
dans la ville du Seigneur
donc c'était quelque chose qui voilà qui
lui tenait à cœur de montrer qu'il n'est
qu'un instrument et je trouve que cette
lecture est bien choisie pour la
circonstance
merci beaucoup et bien écoute on va
continuer à écouter et à suivre et à
vivre cette partie de la célébration
qu'on appelle la liturgie de la parole
avec
la le psaume qui lui est
lui et chanter en latin
tous les jours de ma vie ma demeure est
dans la maison du Seigneur
ont la longueur des jours
[Musique]
passe à mes adversaires
d'une onction tu me parfume la tête ma
coupe des bandes
le Seigneur est mon berger rien ne me
ment sur des prés d'herbes fraîches me
fait reposer
oui grâce et bonheur me presse tous les
jours de ma vie
à demeure
[Musique]
un peu commentaire Bruno Joubert je
voyais au ciné quand
le père Humbert évoquait le latin comme
comme langue internationale
ça c'est vrai que c'est peut-être l'une
des forces du Vatican c'est qu'il
utilise une langue ancienne mais qui
peut s'adresser à tout le monde je pense
que de par le monde on ne se rend pas
compte à quel point les catholiques
post-conciles sont restés
familier d'un certain nombre de prières
de textes de lecture dites en latin et
du coup ça crée un effet cette espèce de
d'impression qui est forte quand on est
dans une cérémonie à la basilique
Saint-Pierre on voit bien qu'à
l'évidence il y a des gens de partout et
lorsque
est prononcé une prière ou chanté
quelque chose en latin il y a une espèce
de montée dans l'assistance de ceux qui
répondent on sent le volume sonore
augmenter c'est tout simplement parce
que les gens se retrouvent d'une
certaine façon dans leur langue et c'est
pour ça que je trouve que le latin
au-delà de toutes les querelles qu'on
peut avoir sur passéisme moderniste mais
c'est la langue des catholique de leur
unité alors là on va revenir cette
fois-ci en anglais puisque c'est
en cette langue qui est lu donc la
seconde lecture de cette messe qui est
une lettre de saint Pierre apôtre le
premier pape dans sa grande miséricorde
Il nous a engendré de nouveau par la
résurrection de Jésus-Christ entre les
morts
pour une vivante espérance
pour un héritage exemple de corruption
de souillure
de fleurs de flétrissures
et que vous est réservé dans les cieux à
vous que
par la foi la puissance de Dieu garde
pour le salut prêt à se manifester au
dernier moment
vous entrez essayer de joies bien qu'il
vous faille encore
quelques temps être affligé par
différentes épreuves
afin que bien éprouver
votre foi plus précieuse que l'or
véritable
[Musique]
que l'on vérifie par le feu
deviennent
un sujet de louange
et demeure de la révélation de
Jésus-Christ
[Musique]
sans le voir encore
très essayé d'une joie
indicible et pleine de gloire
sur l'obtenir l'objet de votre foi
le salut les armes
[Musique]
voilà donc deuxième lecture peut-être un
commentaire père Imbert sur cette sur
cette deuxième lecture et sur cette
épître de Saint-Pierre
[Musique]
oui
c'était plutôt Saint-Pierre nous
introduit dans la question de
l'espérance alors d'abord c'est beau de
se dire que nous entendons le premier
pape dans cette lecture c'est une lettre
qui l'adresse à au fidèle chrétien de
son époque et nous sommes vraiment
introduit accompagnés dans cette
cérémonie des obsèques qui sont qui est
vraiment tourné vers l'espérance et
c'est le c'est le sujet qui a été choisi
pour pour l'église pour essayer de bien
vivre cette célébration qui de fait vue
sa médiatisation permet aussi à
à tout un tas de personnes qui peut-être
ne sont pas forcément familiers des
célébrations liturgiques de d'entendre
quelque chose une parole forte une
parole qui qui donne vraiment le sens de
ce que nous de ce que nous vivons
là célébration continue je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez bien sûr être avec nous
vous pouvez commenter et nous donner vos
souvenirs et vous posez vos questions
bien sûr opérer Humbert qui est à Vienne
mais qui est avec nous et également à
nos invités Bruno Joubert ancien
ambassadeur de France près le Saint
Siège gens Sevilla historien journaliste
auteur polymorphe
et
Camille Lalan berdotique qui a vécu deux
JMJ celle de colonnes les premières 2005
et celles de Madrid en 2013 vous vous
débattez également sur le chat alors
bien sûr tous les opinions toutes les
opinions pourvu qu'elles respectent les
chartes de modération sont les bienvenus
on a des commentaires critiques sur le
catholicisme aucun problème pour les
exprimer mais encore une fois on reste
dans le cadre de la modération et on
évite l'insulte et la calomnie donc ça
c'est une réponse à la fois à Rome et à
Nicolas qui sont en train de débattre
assez aprement entre
entre
on va revenir justement parce que la
question a été soulevée sur les les
affaires de de pédophilie et ce qui est
intéressant on l'a dit je l'ai signalé
en début de cette de ce direct ce matin
le Saint Siège a souligné notamment les
actions du pape Benoît XVI en ce domaine
rapidement peut-être un jean Civilia là
aussi il a il a agi son action est un
est assez méconnue et et il a dû
affronter quand même comme le dit Jérôme
cordelier dans le point ce matin pas mal
d'oppositions en interne sur ces
questions là tu as été encore un de ses
combats quand il était
pressé de la congélation de la foi
dès 2001
fatigue guerre avait voulu avoir a été
l'auteur d'un texte qui pose un centre
de règles disciplinaire sur ce sujet là
tout cas pédophilie avéré dans l'église
de remonter jusqu'à Rome
l'église
demandait que la justice civile soit
sans part de ces cas c'est à dire que
l'église des églises locales transfert
les dossiers et qu'on s'occupe qu'on
s'occupe des victimes qu'on s'occupe des
victimes donc le carnaval a été un des
premiers au sommet de l'église apprend
le dossier à bras le corps sur ce
dossier bien sûr très important
après
l'Évangile et l'homélie que nous allons
entendre c'est l'heure de l'Évangile
lecture de l'évangile de saint Luc
chapitre 1
suspendu à la croix
l'incurité injurier
n'es-tu pas le Christ toi aussi
sur toi toi-même et nous aussi
mais l'autre le reprenait
[Musique]
tu n'as même pas crainte de Dieu alors
que tu subis la même peine
pour nous c'est justice
[Musique]
et lui n'a rien fait de mal
et il disait Jésus
souviens-toi de moi
lorsque tu viendras avec ton royaume
[Musique]
et il lui dit
en vérité je te le dis aujourd'hui
[Musique]
tu seras avec moi dans le paradis
c'est la sixième heure
pour le soleil s'éclipsa
l'obscurité se fit sur la terre entière
[Musique]
jusqu'à la neuvième heure
le voile du sanctuaire se déchira par le
milieu
je tends un grand cri
Jésus dit père
entre tes mains je remets mon esprit
ayant dit cela
[Musique]
du Seigneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va retourner à Vienne avoir juste un
commentaire juste de la part du père
Imbert avant d'entendre l'homélie du
pape François
c'est l'Évangile l'Évangile particulière
sur
les dernières heures
du Christ pourquoi cet évangile
aujourd'hui
là aussi il y a quelque chose de il y a
un très beau message pour tellement de
personnes qui suivent aujourd'hui cette
célébration de se dire que nous
entendons le les dernières paroles de
Jésus qui s'adresse à
Ron qui sont assez cotés l'un qui est
endurci ils sont dans le mal qui l'a
commis tandis que le deuxième
ému par l'innocence de celui qui est
crucifié ce tourne vers lui et dans
l'instant il reçoit cette réponse
aujourd'hui même tu seras avec moi dans
le paradis alors bien sûr que en une
célébration d'obsèques entendent une
parole comme ça là est très belle et
puis en même temps elle nous remet de
nouveau devant l'humidité de du pape
Benoît qui qui sans cesse et lorsqu'il
parlait de lui et lorsqu'on parlait de
lui faisait référence à cette humilité
on va écouter justement le l'homélie
merci pour ces précisions du pape
François
ce qui a gardé toute sa vie
entre les mains du Seigneur
et de miséricorde
entre entre les mains de ses frères et
de ses sœurs
l'amour que Dieu a pour nous et que nous
croyons en lui pas
je remets mon esprit
l'invitation et le programme de vie
revu
le cœur du pasteur
que ceux du Christ Jésus
que celui qui a remis Jésus
et la condition
c'est sur le Seigneur
et sous la protection de mes mains
pour vous
prions
entre les carrefours et les
contradictions que le pasteur doit
affronter
ses épaules la fatigue et l'intercession
pour son peuple
doit lutter et où les frères voient leur
dignité menacée
du fait de savoir
[Musique]
et ses décisions au temps de Dieu
aimer veut dire aussi être prêt à
souffrir
donner aux brebis le vrai bien une
nourriture de la vérité de Dieu c'est la
Parole de Dieu la nourriture de sa
présence soutenu
par la consolation de l'esprit
on a perdu les images on va essayer de
le retrouver donc le pape François qui
disait que c'est un development soutenu
par la consolation de l'esprit qu'il
précède toujours dans la mission on est
à la fin du enfin ce qui est prévu de
l'homélie peut-être un premier un
premier commentaire avec vous père père
Humbert
à Vienne
c'est
ce qu'on vient d'entendre de la part du
pape François en tous les cas un
commentaire qui est vraiment lié au
lecture du jour
l'exercice même de l'homélie
je vois qu'il est revenu peut-être que
nous pouvons m'écouter jusqu'à la fin si
vous voulez
accomplira sa promesse comme il avait
promis à nos pères et à descendants à
jamais
nous aussi fermement attachés aux
dernières paroles du Seigneur et aux
témoignage qui a permis qui a marqué sa
vie nous voulons en tant que communauté
ecclésiale
suivre ces traces et confier notre frère
aux mains du Père
le chemin de miséricorde trouve sa lampe
allumée
durant sa vie entière
Saint-Grégoire le Grand à la fin de sa
règle passerale invite exhorte un ami à
lui offrir sa vie ok compagnie table sur
tes prières
[Musique]
c'est la conscience du pasteur qui ne
peut pas tout seul ceux qui en réalité
il sapiens ça aide délicatesse ça a été
dit
le peuple fidèle de Dieu rassemblée
et Koffi la vie de celui qui a été son
pasteur
nous sommes ici avec le parfum de la
gratitude les languant de l'espérance
pour lui démontrer encore une fois
l'amour qui ne se perd pas nous voulons
faire entendre
la même voix
que notre joie soit complètement savoir
une fécondité invisible insaisissable
qui n'est du fait de savoir dans
quel dans lesquelles la confiance a été
placée une confiance priante et
adoratrice voici donc les premiers mots
les mots
prononcés à l'instant par le pape
François
on va aller à Vienne
retrouver le père Clément Imbert
qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué dans ce que
l'on vient d'entendre du pape François
j'ai trouvé très beau de rester très
proche des lectures et spécialement de
lecture qui nous parle du du pasteur il
nous fait une description du pasteur en
regardant la personne du Christ et nous
comprenons aussi qu'il nous fait aussi
la présentation de son prédécesseur en
le sans avoir réellement besoin de le
mentionner
notamment en évoquant le fait de
souffrir celui qui aime souffre pour ses
brebis je crois que nous en avons parlé
auparavant le pape Benoît n'a pas reculé
devant les épreuves et les souffrances
par amour pour pour ses brebis pour son
église et puis c'est une façon aussi de
revenir sur le fait que parfois on le
considérait comme réfugié dans ses
livres trop intellectuels mais je crois
en tout cas j'ai moi-même cette
expérience
que c'était véritablement un pasteur et
puis le le Pape a voulu bien sûr offrir
une parole au monde qui qui qu'on écoute
aux chrétiens en rappelant cette chose
fondamentale que
la miséricorde que se tourner vers Dieu
au moment de la cérémonie d'obsèques que
ce soit pour le pape ou pour toute
personne c'est implorer la miséricorde
de Dieu et c'est obtenir cette réponse
spontanée du Seigneur à chaque fois
qu'on se tourne vers lui la réponse
qu'il fait au mauvais larron est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir personne plus
éloignée d'une certaine façon que celui
qui est condamné pour les crimes alors
le Seigneur lui donne cette réponse il
suffit simplement de se tourner de
demander pardon donc il me semble qu'il
y a beaucoup de choses qui sont dites
dans cette obèse
merci beaucoup pour ces premiers
commentaires quelque chose qui vous a
frappé dans cette dans cette Mélie qui a
mis la lameur du truc oui effectivement
en fait on voit en filigrane le portrait
de Jean-Paul de benassès pardon les
quelques mots qui m'ont frappé et qui me
font évidemment penser à bonne Assesse
c'est
le côté on voit le côté fatigue la
graphique de l'intercession l'usure de
l'onction donc le pasteur qui se donne
pour ses brebis et qui et qui souffrent
et qui luttent et
aussi et la façon dont le Seigneur
accueille le Seigneur accueille avec
douceur et on parlait de menaces et de
sa gentillesse et je pense que c'est un
reflet de la bonté de la douceur du
Seigneur on va revenir justement sur les
commentaires de cette homélie mais pour
l'instant c'est la séquence
effectivement ce qu'on appelle la prière
universelle dans l'Église catholique et
où on prie notamment à ce moment-là pas
seulement à ce moment-là mais pour le
pape des fins je vous propose d'écouter
on y revient ensuite en plateau
qu'ils annoncent audacieux
de l'église la victoire du Christ sur le
mal et sur la mort
[Musique]
Seigneur la victoire du Christ sur le
mal et la mort
[Musique]
évoquant le Seigneur te prions en nous
prions en arabe
le chef d'État
qu'il fasse leur possible pour
promouvoir la justice c'est
la vérité
le prix au Seigneur en autonomie nous
prions en portugais
E
faire la pauvreté l'indigence qui est
parmi nous
prie au Seigneur en nous
prions à présent en italien
qui nous ont précédés
qu'ils soient ils ont dans leur royaume
[Musique]
nous envoyons vers toi
le Seigneur
tous les besoins de l'Église et de
l'humanité
et maintenant nous tournons vers la
liturgie le l'Eucharistie
la célébration des funérailles du pape
Benoît XVI est en cours vous pouvez la
suivre en direct bien entendu sur le
site du Figaro sur Youtube vous êtes
nombreux à nous suivre il y a une
question d'ailleurs d'un internaute
africain sur Youtube et je reviendrai
vers vous Bruno Joubert parce que vous
connaissez très bien l'Afrique vous avez
conseillé le président Nicolas Sarkozy
sur ces questions là avant justement de
rejoindre le Saint-Siège
d'abord un commentaire sur ce qu'on a
entendu du pape François de cette de
cette homélie de cet hommage au fait
demain
de dire ma collègue à l'instant sur
le lien direct entre
scanner le pape et Benoît XVI mais j'y
vois un élément supplémentaire c'est que
au fond le pas parle aussi de lui-même
de la charge qui est sur ses épaules et
donc on peut lire dans cette Mélie
peut-être quelque chose d'intéressant
qui est une forme de d'expression assez
rare de la part de Françoise sur sa
charge et en particulier lorsqu'il
lorsqu'il évoque les difficultés pour se
faire comprendre et pour s'accorder aux
décisions accordées ces décisions au
temps on sent bien qu'il doit souffrir
lui aussi des critiques qui doivent
monter qui montrent régulièrement sur un
centre de sujets qui l'aborde et et du
coup je trouve ce texte est très
émouvant
genre je veux bien que le la
renonciation
occulte le pontificate Benoît XVI mais
en écoutant le pape François malgré la
coupure que nous a fait la télé du
Vatican au milieu
j'ai quand même vu un certain nombre
d'allusions à cette à cette renonciation
oui bien sûr je sens le Pape a dit le
Pape François l'a dit il a dit que il
excluait pas cette possibilité qu'il
envisageait pour lui-même si s'il est
arrivé au bout de ses forces donc il est
possible que il y a plus lui-même sur
cette touche le jour où j'y suis
vraiment ça sera trop lourd et j'allais
dire moi j'ai eu le même sentiment que
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur il y a quelques
phrases on a l'impression qu'il parle
aussi de lui quand il parle de la loi de
la charge et si derrière parce qu'au
fond ça rapproche les deux hommes le
bord le vivant le prédécioles successeur
qui sont très différents sous tout un
tas de plans et avec des oppositions
feutrées qu'on ne connaîtra jamais ou
peut-être dans 100 ans si certaines
choses sortent des archives mais là ils
sont au fond d'une grande proximité
parce qu'ils sont de la même situation
donc oui il est pas exclu que le pape
François choisisse de renoncer
de suite de renoncement de renonciation
de consécutive
commencerait à produire une forte de
coup de tube une forme de jurisprudence
effectivement maintenant tant que il y a
rien d'inscrit dans les textes le
subconscient pontificale comme le disait
Vincent hervois sur Europe 1 ce matin
n'est pas une monarchie de type
politique c'est pas un monarchie on
n'est pas par le sang comme on est roi
ou empereur de père en fils c'est une
chat oui c'est une charge qu'on
comprend sur son dos donc et il a encore
il y a rien écrit officiellement dans
les textes c'était le successeur de
François peut-être annoncera jamais on
n'en sait rien il y a quand même une
chose qui frappe d'ailleurs le père
Imbert le disait à l'instant le nom du
pape François n'est pas mentionné dans
ce dans ce dans ce dans cette Mélie le
nom
et l'oeuvre du pape François du pape
Benoît n'est pas tellement n'est pas
tellement
pas du tout évoqué il y a quelque chose
qui frappait quand
razzinger avait fait avait fait le Meli
du sermon le ménélite de les funérailles
de Jean-Paul II c'est qu'il faisait
référence à l'oeuvre à la vie de
Jean-Paul II et également même au
dernier instant de de Jean-Paul II il y
a quand même un contraste là de ce point
là aussi
[Musique]
a été le bras droit de Jean-Paul II
pendant pendant 20 ans il y avait entre
une amitié
humaine intellectuelle spirituelle
carnet pas le même rapport ni avec le
Carla de singer ni Benoît sait c'est un
secret pour personne sans vouloir
assister sur des différences elles sont
réelles elles sont connues bon donc
je pense il y a pas la même à charge
affective personnelle pour lui de de
grossesse que qu'il n'y avait pour
Benoît XVI d'intérêt Jean-Paul II
il y a quand même une phrase
à la fin donc de l'homélie de du pape
François une citation d'impact d'un
grand pape c'est Grégoire le Grand
qui dit qui invite et exhorte un ami à
lui offrir la compagnie spirituelle au
milieu des tempêtes de ma vie je me
console par la confiance que tu me
tiendras à flot sur la table de tes
prières que si le point de mes fautes
là-bas est humilie tu me prêteras le
secours de tes mérites pour me relever
est-ce que c'est pas également un
hommage à ce qui a été pendant ces 9
années Benoît XVI dans sa retirée dans
son monastère mater eclayé au Vatican
qui a dit qu'il continuait mais dans la
prière qui continue sa charge mais dans
la prière et c'est d'ailleurs c'est
étonnant je pense que pas François est
le seul papa avoir eu pendant si
longtemps un prédécesseur ça n'a pas
être évident de de prendre une charge en
sachant que le prédécesseur est toujours
là et forcément
je pense que Benoit 16 avait l'humilité
suffisante pour pour rester en retrait
mais et pour prier et sans sans juger
pour accompagner mais effectivement il y
avait sûrement cette communion
spirituelle on savait Bruno Joubert des
relations entre les deux hommes dans les
ambassades
on a découvert beaucoup après l'élection
de François
ce qu'on savait surtout c'est que
François lorsqu'il venait à Rome se
tenait beaucoup à l'écart
des autres cardinaux irrésidés dans la
maison du clergé qui est auprès de ça de
Saint-Louis des Français il se met les
peu à la vie sociale que parfois les
cardinaux vie sociale entre eux je veux
dire il était donc un peu à part alors
sur le plan humain
on savait pas on n'avait pas le
sentiment qu'il y a eu de lien
spécifique entre eux ni non plus
d'ailleurs d'opposition alors après les
oppositions une fois que le magistère a
débuté on a mis en avant les différences
et on les a vu apparaître très très vite
il y a en effet le très grandes
différences dans la conception que ces
deux hommes se font
de leur action une des difficultés pour
revenir à ce que vous dites sur
l'homélie pourquoi il n'a pas évoqué
l'oeuvre de Benoît XVI
qui suis-je pour pour parler de cette
œuvre mais je crois que ça doit être
assez difficile
d'exprimer en quelques mots
ce qu'a été l'oeuvre de Benoît parce que
elle a été plus dans l'ordre de la foi
donc d'une certaine façon de
l'intangible du difficile à exprimer
quelque chose de doux et de continuer
alors que l'action ça a été celle de
Jean-Claude ou maintenant de François
depuis le début souvent le pape François
en dépit des différents justement a
quand même souligné à très grande
maintes fois il a dit que
Benoît XVI à la cigarette était à des
très grandes théologiens d'église
catholique donc en dépit de leurs
différences François tu reconnais je
dirais pas cette supériorité
du cadre non mais j'ai qu'on y voit
aucune il n'y a pas de je mets pas de
mauvais esprit là dedans mais je pense
que le pape François cette humilité là
il les a pas toujours toutes les
humilités mais celle-là il l'a au moins
de reconnaître qu'il y a une supériorité
du Racinger de l'oeuvre intellectuelle
théologique de par rapport à son apport
à lui et est-ce qu'on peut voir
justement également à travers ce texte
et à travers les rapports qu'ils avaient
en tous les cas qu'il montrait qui était
mise en scène qu'il y avait en clair
[Musique]
jamais encore rendu en France au bout de
9 ans pour psychia c'est un tout petit
peu troublant pour les catholiques
français alors il s'est rendu en France
mais dans le Rolande c'est-à-dire à
Strasbourg et c'est peut-être ce jour-là
qu'on a vu la grande différence sur des
deux entre les deux hommes sur leur
rapport à l'Europe puisque c'est ce
jour-là ou le pape François a dit que
l'Europe était une grand-mère stérile
mais oui et c'est très clair je crois
fondamentalement si on fait le jeu des
différences que François apporte quelque
chose tout à fait novateur à la fonction
pontificale il vient c'est une
tautologie de Buenos Aires c'est-à-dire
d'une de ces très grandes agglomérations
mondiales où se trouvent des gens
désormais la majorité de la population
il apporte là une vision du rôle de la
foi dans ces espaces-là qui n'était pas
celle à l'évidence que portait de
l'ancienne
peut-être un commentaire on va laisser
vivre justement ces instants et on y
revient après je vous propose une
question
[Musique]
vers vous parce qu'on vient de faire
silence parce que bien entendu c'est le
moment le plus important pour les
catholiques on vient de vivre le monde
de l'élévation
donc on est au cœur de la foi catholique
et également est-ce que c'est pas là un
des grands souvenirs de JMJ à Cologne à
Madrid où on avait avant sous Jean-Paul
II était sous pas François un pape qui
est plutôt un PAPSTAR qui est vraiment
occupe le devant de la scène et là
c'était plutôt le pape François celui
qui faisait un pas de côté sur la scène
et qui justement
avait essayé plein les images que l'on a
souvent les photos qu'on a souvent du
pape François c'est avec un ostensoir
cette grand objet à dans lequel on met
l'hostie le corps du Christ qui le
brandissait sur les sur les sur les
astrages oui c'est vrai que le peu
Benoît XV était pas un pop star on a
vraiment l'impression que il
ne cherchez pas à attirer les
projecteurs vers lui il était presque
parfois même un peu gêné un peu
maladroit
je me souviens quand à Cologne il
remontait le fleuve dans un dans un dans
un bateau et on le voit il est assis il
sait pas s'il faut se lever s'il faut
s'asseoir il est un petit peu il est un
petit peu perdu donc on sent qu'il est
un petit peu perdu mais en fait
effectivement la personne pour qui il
est c'est pour qu'il est venu c'est
c'est le Christ pour me c'est pour nous
nous l'apporter nous le donner
effectivement moi j'ai toujours été un
très frappé quand dans de grands
rassemblements par exemple assez GMJ que
ce soit Cologne ou Madrid le coffre le
pape
lève l'ostensoir ou se trouve
effectivement la présence réelle de
Christ dans dans l'hostie et béni
l'assemblée et nous bénit moi je me dis
à chaque fois cette personne qui porte
le Christ
c'est vraiment c'est peut-être encore
plus et encore mieux et là une relation
encore plus incroyable avec avec le
Christ et elle nous l'offre et c'est
très poignant comme
je je viens vers vous Jean parce que
précisément dans la France catholique
votre livre que vous avez écrit
justement sur les évolutions de la
pratique de la foi en France vous notez
que
ce culte du Saint-Sacrement l'adoration
du Saint-Sacrement et l'un des faits
majeurs dans la piété des catholiques de
la fin du 20e siècle et début du 20e
siècle oui tout à fait la pratique de
l'adoration alors pour le spectateur on
se rappelle que
initié pour dans la théologie catholique
au moment de la consécration à la messe
le style devient sustentiellement par la
structure sensation le corps du Christ
et donc et donc la pratique de
l'adoration de caractéristiques c'est la
prière silencieuse devant l'hostie
consacré et qui était du tradition très
ancienne dans les années 60 70
est tombé en désuétude par
pardonne-moi de vous poser cette
question un peu banale un peu triviale
mais quel est l'ambiance comment a été
reçu écouté
ce serment du pape François est-ce qu'on
a observé les mêmes ferveur que l'on
pouvait observer pendant le
les funérailles de Jean-Paul II
apparemment à l'inverse des funérailles
de Jean-Paul II le célébrant n'a pas été
interrompu par les applaudissements
oui tout à fait Vincent ce qui est
frappant ici sur la place Saint-Pierre
c'est vraiment se recueillement des des
fidèles cette ambiance très brillante je
justement j'ai profité de de ce sermon
de cet homélie pour aller me promener au
milieu des fidèles et puis je puis bien
je peux vous dire que il y a vraiment
très peu de bruit les gens ne parlent
pas entre eux les livrets de messe sont
ouverts et les gens vraiment sont en
train de prier des gens sont en train
était en train à ce moment-là d'écouter
l'homélie du du pape François mais voilà
les gens sont très disciplinés on va
dire ici en tous les cas sont vraiment
dans cette atmosphère de recueillement
tout à l'heure au début de la messe
lorsque le cercueil du pape Benoît 16 a
été présenté en face au pied de l'hôtel
pardon et bien là aussi de quelques
timides applaudissements mais vraiment
voilà c'est resté très timide et ici les
gens sont vraiment en train de de prier
pendant pendant cette messe qui se
poursuit sous ce ciel nuageux de Rome
même avec beaucoup de de brouillard et
ce qui contraste pas mal beaucoup avec
ce grand soleil ce grand ciel bleu
d'hier ici voilà vraiment c'est une
ambiance très brillante une ambiance de
recueillement alors que certaines
personnes continuent de d'arriver vers
cette place Saint-Pierre peut-être des
touristes Romains ça parle
principalement italien et voilà et les
quelques touristes qui continuent se
promener
aux abords de cette de cette place
Saint-Pierre alors précisément juste
Timothée
quel est l'influence est-ce que la place
Saint-Pierre est pleine on n'a pas
l'impression que l'Avia de la
conciliation qui descend de la place
Saint-Pierre et noir demande comme on
avait pu le voir notamment au moment du
conclave
oui c'est vrai que le Vatican ne s'était
pas risqué à donner un chiffre sur
l'influence pour cette cette messe on
attendait nous disait-on entre 60000 et
100 000 personnes ici ce qui est certain
c'est que la place Saint-Pierre à
proprement parler et pleine il y a même
des fidèles qui se tiennent debout donc
vers le fond de la de la place en
revanche pour ce qui est de la vieille
la conciliation donc cette cette grande
vue cette grande avenue cette grande
artère qui mène sur la place
Saint-Pierre elle voilà beaucoup de
passages de va-et-vient mais elle n'est
pas pleine de fidèles il y a des
barrières mais qui voilà qui qui pour
l'instant j'allais j'allais dire de
servent à rien je ne sais pas mais en
tous les cas voilà on a effectivement en
tête ces images de certains fidèles
contre les barrières etc là ce n'est pas
le cas la Via de la conciliation est
vide même s'il y a évidemment beaucoup
de va-et-vient par contraste avec cette
place Saint-Pierre qui elle pour le coup
et pleine noir de monde merci beaucoup
Timothée vous restez avec nous et vous
revenez en direct pour nous signaler
les prochains développement et puis on
va continuer de vivre avec vous cette
célébration Jean vous vouliez faire un
commentaire
tes détails mais par rapport à
l'affluence je suis pas sûr les lieux
par définition mais enfin dehors ce qui
me frappe c'est le nombre de prêtres
avec leurs reconnaît alors des sols
rouges et vu de haut on a vu qu'il faut
revenir dans le carré extrêmement
important donc ça veut dire que le
clergé il a reçu Benoît XVI il est là
pour lui rendre hommage c'est très
important et par ailleurs pour ce qui
est de l'influence globale il faudrait
pas comparer une chose comparables faut
pas oublier que pour les obsèques de
Jean-Paul II les Polonais étaient venus
par dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
donc c'était extrêmement important Rome
était une ville polonaise à ce jour-là
donc
comparant ce qui est comparable certes
comparant ce qui est comparable mais
pardonnez-moi d'abord les Allemands ne
viennent pas en masse
apparemment aux dernières aux dernières
révolution dans l'église alors je pense
que
la révolution dans l'église ce que
j'appelle le chemin sinodal de l'église
d'Allemagne qui pose un centre de
questions qui va poser
des gravissimes si les choses ne se
réglent pas entre Rome et et et les
piscopa allemande et tout un peu à
l'église d'Allemagne qui est en qui est
en train de prendre un chemin qui est
totalement contraire à celui de la
tradition catholique est-ce qu'on peut
dire que Benoît XVI n'a pas été prophète
en son pays mais il était déjà pas déjà
quand une grande partie de l'épiscopa
allemande était opposés à Joseph hard
Seigneur avant même qu'il ne fuit pas et
son élection n'a pas réjouis tous les
Allemands je veux dire l'église
d'Allemagne l'Allemagne est un pays de
tradition protestante aussi donc ça se
retrouve parfois chez les catholiques
alors on a tendance à souvent opposer
Benoît XVI et le pape François mais
est-ce que justement le pape François ne
sait pas
mis dans les pas de Benoît 16 sur cette
question la question allemande
puisqu'il a il a eu une formule il y a
déjà une école il y a déjà une église
protestante il y a pas besoin d'en avoir
une deuxième c'est-à-dire que si je si
je pouvais simplifier les choses au
maximum je dirais que pas pour soi et de
passer sur sa gauche par glisse
d'Allemagne
et là évidemment il va réagir je pense
que la force de l'institution va faire
qu'il va réagir comme un pape et y
compris peut-être par rapport à certains
de ces vues mais il va être obligé pour
maintenir la cohésion de de jouer la
tradition on va revenir justement sur
ces questions d'affluence qui derrière
bien sûr qui passionne toujours les
journalistes mais qui révèle un certain
nombre de choses et je voudrais qu'on on
y fasse en cigarette à l'instant Bruno
Joubert
le sur Youtube cette question la
religion on a vu tout à l'heure un
cardinal africain qu'on célébré je sais
pas si tu es le gardien de Sarah il me
semble pas mais en tout cas il a vieilli
la religion chrétienne nous dit cette
internaute est réservée uniquement pour
les occidentaux et non pour les
Africains car chaque peuple à sa culture
l'Afrique noire a sa spiritualité
c'est une réaction de l'ancien
conseiller Afrique de l'Élysée oublier
que la chrétienté est née en Orient ce
qui est une première chose ensuite
parce que Rome était la capitale du
monde de l'époque
ensuite elle s'est aussi propagée à peu
près des époques plus tardives vers l'un
de vers toute une série d'endroits y
compris la Chine c'est une autre
histoire mais pour ce qui est de
l'Afrique l'Afrique est actuellement
pour moi la partie la plus
exceptionnellement dynamique de l'essor
de la religion catholique auto regarde
l'Occident on dira l'église se flétrit
elle n'est plus que l'ombre d'elle-même
je n'en sais rien c'est pas le propos
mais en Afrique elle est
extraordinairement dynamique et quand on
voit le cardinal Sarah que vous venez de
mentionner moi je suis profondément ému
par le cardinal Sarah quand on imagine
que cet homme est venu de Guinée au
confins du Sénégal à une époque où on
voyait peu et qu'il a acquis et qu'il
est devenu à des plus importants
cardinaux de la curie romaine il est
bien la démonstration lui par sa
personne de ce cas d'universel en effet
le message
évangélique et qui fait qu'un jeune
africain venu du bon du bout de
l'Afrique et capable d'être aussi un des
grands cardinaux de l'Église catholique
ça pour moi c'est une démonstration
vous vous l'avez très bien dit le
message du Christ s'adresse à tout le
monde et peut rejoindre absolument tout
le monde après c'est sûr qu'il y a des
des esprits et des traditions et des
cultures différentes mais moi on parlait
tout à l'heure des langues et là on
voyait on parlait du latin qui est
effectivement pour moi une langue un peu
universelle et un peu aussi éternel
parce qu'elle traverse les siècles mais
je suis aussi très marquée par par
toutes les langues qui ont été utilisées
là pendant cette pendant cette
célébration
c'est intéressant de voir que l'Église
s'adapte enfin pas que l'Église s'adapte
à chaque à chaque culture séduisant
toutes les prières etc et même encore
plus loin les apparitions quand notre
Dame apparaît à Bernadette Soubirou à
Lourdes elle lui parle dans son dans son
dans sa langue que ça il m'accouda je
trouve ça magnifique d'être rejoint
comme ça dans son petit patois voilà
quand ça lui d'ailleurs tous les
habitants de Lourdes et du sud de la
France qui sont là je salue notamment
les internautes du Figaro qui sont
également en direct Vlad et Nicolas
Charles certains ont soutenu qu'on
l'avait poussé dehors mais je n'y crois
pas nous dit Charles à 85 ans on a le
droit d'être fatigué et c'est peut-être
aussi l'un des messages que nous
subliminaux qui a adressé à travers cet
homélie le pape François si je vous ai
si je vous ai bien compris
Jean notamment
une question
par rapport maintenant à cette question
de l'influence je vous livrer une
anecdote personnelle puisque on a eu le
plaisir d'avoir le père Humbert
donc
le je vois Philippe jelly qui nous dit
vous pourriez mettre des blancs titres
pour qu'on sache qui parle effectivement
on a eu des questions de réalisation qui
fait qu'on peut pas mettre toujours des
bantines donc j'en sais via historien
journaliste Camille Hélène berduti dès
qu'il a été
au deuxième J qui fait partie de
l'association catovoice et Bruno Joubert
ancien ambassadeur de France au Vatican
ambassadeur de France près de Saint
Siège très exactement on revient donc à
cette question de l'influence cette
anecdote où on a eu donc on a eu tout à
l'heure un prêtre très difficile
aujourd'hui d'avoir un prêtre pour
commenter cette série cette cérémonie
alors on peut dire ils sont pris sur les
autres plateaux il y en a certains c'est
le cas actuellement notamment sur France
mais ce qui est frappant c'est que les
prêtres qui se définissent notamment en
région parisienne comme ratzingeria très
proche disent qu'ils ont été très
marqués etc beaucoup continuent leurs
activités aujourd'hui
leur activité administrative en ce
moment même c'est en tout cas la raison
qui a été invoquée mais c'est une raison
qui je pense réelle parce que c'est
quelque chose
on voit qu'il y a un certain nombre de
de
il y a certes nucléaire j'ai mais il y a
pas énormément d'affluences
est-ce que finalement il reste grand
chose de Benoît XV
il faudrait il faut remettre tout en
perspective historique faut pas oublier
que Jean-Paul II a modifié quelque part
la fonction pontificat si vous voulez
si on remontait loin dans l'histoire je
pense qu'un paysan breton sous Louis XIV
s'il ne connaissait même pas le nom du
pape
Jeanne d'Arc ne savait pas qu'il y avait
trois papes
si vous voulez
à partir du phénomène de monarchie
forticale qui sait solidifié à partir du
19e siècle
pie 9 etc et puis les moyens de
communication moderne on fait que le
pape est devenu un personnage visible
radio télévision et puis enfin à partir
de Paul 6 et pape qui est sorti du
Vatican et puis Jean-Paul II est allé
dans le monde entier c'est-à-dire que le
paysan purifient péruvien sachez qu'il
savait qu'ils ont se trouver un pape du
nom le pape est devenu un personnage
mais du coup il y a cet effet qui est un
petit peu à tranchant c'est que cette
personne était énorme avec un plan de
cas si long sceptif sur tous les plans
il a il a il a lesté la fonction
musicale d'une charge considérable
si vous voulez pour les catholiques
français
l'enterrement de pions n'était pas un
élément si considérable et quel type
français lors de la mort depuis
pour son pour son enterrement vous voyez
ce que j'ai c'est que c'est qu'on est
nous très marqué par l'image de
Jean-Paul II et en fait il est possible
je pourrais répondre à votre question
j'ai préparément un peu de temps pour le
commissariat c'est parce que je crois
que il est possible pour en revienne à
une fonction plus vision plus modeste de
la du rôle du rôle du pape la fonction
boticale elle n'est pas modifiée par
définition elle est la même depuis
depuis 20 siècle mais du personnage du
pape il est possible qu'on revienne à
une vision plus plus simple plus modeste
c'est à dire un petit peu en filigrane
dans certains textes du cardinal pas
lui-même et de Benoît XVI est-ce que
c'est pas justement à la fois Bruno
Joubert dans ce qu'il dit dans les
fameuses conversations les premières
conversations publiées avec Peter Sival
Lydie un pape quand il ne peut plus peu
et droit même renoncer
et à travers la façon dont il a exécé il
était tout en tous les cas sur scène je
peux dire il était tout sauf car ils ont
dit alors justement c'est bien ce qui
vient de dire et je trouve qu'il a toute
profondément raison on s'est pris au jeu
du pack médiatique c'est évidemment
extrêmement rassurant notamment pour
l'Église catholique de constater que le
Saint Père draine des foules immenses
que les chefs d'État se précipitent que
ça
concrétise l'idée d'une résurgence d'une
force de l'église je crois justement que
paradoxalement Benoît XV quand on parle
de continuité ou pas là il est dans la
rupture complète
ce qui n'a aucun moment peut-être par
défiance de lui-même peut-être par
tempérament aucun moment voulu croisez
le faire sur ce terrain là avec son
prédécesseur il sait même il sait même
comment dire poser en termes doctrino et
de magistère comme étant parfaitement
indifférent à ce que l'opinion est il y
avait une opinion qui lui était
fondamentalement style depuis le début
il s'est dit c'est pas grave c'est pas
ça qui m'importe c'est comme ça qu'on a
cette idée d'un pape qui a été très
intérieur très voué aux choses de
l'église du coup moins compréhensible
pas charismatique vous l'avez dit ça
c'est clair mais ne le cherchant pas non
plus et même allant au devant de
l'affrontement avec ceux qui lui
reprochaient justement de pas en faire
assez pour l'opinion ou trop pour
l'opinion c'est pas effectivement un
pape médiatique
est-ce que justement il y avait pas eu
est-ce qu'il n'a pas vu d'être un risque
de dérive chez Jean-Paul II en tous les
cas pas dans la personne Jean-Paul II
pas dans l'exercice de Jean-Paul II mais
dans cette tentation dans l'exercice de
la de la papauté qu'on une forme
d'idolâtrie ou une forme de
stérification ce qui en tout cas
Monseigneur bouger de rappeler samedi
il nous rappelle que le chef de l'Église
c'est le Christ oui c'est absolument
vous avez dit isolatrice et c'est trop
fort mais enfin je pense qu'en effet le
personnage Jean-Paul II a beaucoup
écrasé et l'effort de de tous les forts
de Benoît XV c'est de rappeler que tout
vient du Christ et que le pape n'est que
Michael Vicaire du Christ donc ce qui
est important c'est le Christ c'est pas
son picaire et donc de soins du lin il y
a aussi un apport de Benoît 16
justement l'une des caractéristiques de
Jean-Paul 2 et de son charisme et de sa
rencontre auprès des jeunes qu'on a
longtemps présenté c'était parce que il
était le pape Rockstar c'était le cas le
pape enfin c'est puis c'était une vraie
bête de scène c'est un acteur de théâtre
d'ailleurs au départ et
ce qui n'était absolument pas le cas de
Benoît XVI comment ça qui est une
question comment justement sens charisme
en étant quand même une approche
purement intellectuelle il a pu susciter
autant d'enthousiasme notamment dans un
pays dont il n'avait pas la sensibilité
méditerranéenne qui était l'Espagne en
2011 effectivement on était à Cologne
pour les gyms je n’était un peu plus
d'un million et les les
îles après c'était Ciney donc trop
nombreux et on était 2 millions 2001 en
Espagne en fait je pense que il y a
quelque chose qui reste très touchant
chez lui de simplicité en fait c'est
c'est agréable d'avoir un pape qui est
très à l'aise qui est très charismatique
et effectivement
Jean-Paul deux acteurs il sait il
s'amène une scène mais est-ce que c'est
ça qu'on attend d'un pape je suis pas
sûr moi j'ai l'impression que ce que
j'attende un peuple c'est quelqu'un qui
me qui me fasse avancer vers le Christ
dans l'église qui me voilà donc et c'est
exactement ce qu'a fait ce qui a fait
Benoît 16 donc on n'a pas besoin de ça
c'est plaisant quand ça existe mais
c'est pas nécessaire est-ce qu'il est
encore lu étudié
dans les pays de sa langue de pays que
vous connaissez bien genre l'Allemagne
et l'Autriche
je change de pays où j'en étais Dieu
tout à l'heure où il y a une crise
également notre riche oui oui oui c'est
sur le même plan il y a une crise de
l'église très profond du catholicisme
dans les pays de langue germanique et en
ce moment qui est une crise très très
profonde qui
donc à une contestation profonde de
certains points qui sont ceux de la
traditionnellement d'actrices catholique
de toute vision l'organisation de
l'Église on est au début d'un processus
dont
un tournevis c'est pas seulement le pape
François qui va devoir affronter la
question c'est c'est le pape suivant
donc
Ratzinger chez lui n'est pas toujours
bien reçu
on parlait un certain nombre de dossiers
on a parlé tout à l'heure de la
pédophilie juste peut-être pour terminer
sur ce dossier peut-être vos souvenirs
également en tant qu'ambassadeur vous
êtes arrivés d'ailleurs les prix vos
fonctions après une grosse crise celle
de 2009 qui était l'année que le pape
Benoît XVI avait consacré à au sacerdoce
au prêtre et qui a été
méthodiquement on peut dire marquer par
par un certain nombre de scandales
retentissants notamment en Europe
comment vous avez perçu justement la
détermination du pape Benoît XVI sur ces
questions là et est-ce que ça l'était
est-ce que c'était suffisamment perçu à
l'époque alors c'est bizarre la question
votre question est très juste à Rome
tous ceux qui étaient sur sur place ce
rendez bien compte que de la part de
Benoît XVI avait une véritable
sentiment de scandale volonté de faire
avancer les choses mais ce qui
surprenait aussi c'était à quel point
cette volonté ne semblait pas trouver sa
traduction dans les diocèses sur le
terrain et et moi c'était une de mes
interrogations pendant longtemps comment
se fait-il qu'entre le la parole du
Saint Père toutes les manifestations
évidentes de ce qu'il était profondément
décidé à ce que ça change et
la courroie de transmission verglise
tout ça n'a pas fonctionné très bien ou
plutôt il y a eu une latence terrible
parce qu'on a fait remonter des affaires
les unes après les autres et qu'au fond
il fallait faire beaucoup plus qu'il n'a
fait même s'il avait lui cette volonté
de le faire pour que finalement
encore maintenant on arrive à purger un
petit peu cette dette terrible que porte
l'église contemporaine
un commentaire peut-être sur ce que on
va voir donc là on est dans les rites en
purement des funérailles alors que l'on
voit la Une du journal officiel du saint
ciel l'Observatoire et Romano alors
quelques ruptures de faisceau et dès
qu'on les retrouve les images et bien on
va les regarder
et on va les vivre en direct
bénédiction du corps de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le noir
[Musique]
alors peut-être un commentaire sur les
personnes que l'on voit actuellement à
l'écran à l'antenne Jean Sévilla le
secrétaire du pape de nantaise
qui sort le fils spirituel des jeunes de
franzinger plusieurs fois des discours
qui a fait enfin
ces dernières années dernier mois où il
pleurait notamment enfin je veux dire
son maître en quelque sorte souffrir
autant mon Seigneur gunswagen qui était
parti en vacances d'ailleurs en début de
semaine et qui est dû revenir
précipitamment
à partir donc du milieu de semaine le
pape François qui plonge sa tête
dans les mains on a vu également Bruno
Joubert une femme à côté de Monseigneur
gunswang il y a eu pas mal de femmes qui
ont travaillé autour du pape Benoît XVI
à dire la vérité je ne connais pas leur
nom mais c'est aussi une des idées
fausses sur le Saint Siège sur le
Vatican c'est que en réalité il y a
beaucoup de femmes dans tous les
erreurs simplement ils n'ont pas été
suffisamment et elles n'ont été plus
sous François promu à des fonctions de
responsabilité mais pour parler de Radio
Vatican pour parler la somme de
d'endroits où on y trouvait énormément
de femmes en responsabilité déjà
mais je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
comment dirige quelques un marqueur
qu'on puisse
rapporter à l'action de Benoît est-ce
que vous pouvez nous préciser qui sont
les personnes qui vont porter le
cercueil du pape Benoît XVI
moi j'aurais tendance à dire ce sont des
cent pétriniens c'est-à-dire les sans
pétriniens sont des personnels attachés
à la basilique Saint-Pierre qui dépend
de ce qu'on appelle la fabrique de
Saint-Pierre c'est-à-dire
l'administration du Vatican qui gère en
permanence cette basilique énorme qui a
besoin de travaux qui a besoin et dont
le service intérieur les changements de
décor si je puis dire sont assurés par
ces
sans pétriniens et le terme par lequel
on les désigne et qui sont des Italiens
le plus souvent de famille proche de
l'église je réponds à cette internaute
qui nous demande qui est le cardinal qui
a dit la messe et qui bénit le cercueil
il s'agit du cardinal c'est le cardinal
ré qui est le doyen du Sacré-Collège
c'est-à-dire le plus ancien des
cardinaux il a tenu une place importante
dans les conclave qui se sont tenus
notamment au moment de l'élection de
Benoît puis au moment de l'élection
de François sont successeur c'est donc
une figure on a même dit à un moment
donné qu'il aurait pu être papabilé je
ne l'ai jamais vraiment cru mais en tout
cas c'est une figure importante du
Collège des Cardinaux à Rome
avec Benoît XVI était le dernier
vivant qu'avoir été écrit cardinal par
Paul 6 donc qui était le prédécesseur de
Jean-Paul II et qui est comme Jean-Paul
II d'ailleurs a été canonisé
on va continuer à vivre ces derniers
instants ce qui se passe maintenant
Bruno Joubert c'est que normalement le
cercueil doit être
doté jusque dans la dans la crypte
jusque dans les
sous-sols de la basilique ou reposent la
plupart des des pontifs à l'exception de
ceux qui ayant été canonisés on le
privilège d'aller si je puis dire être
exposé dans la basilique elle-même je
vous je vous arrête et bien on voit on
voit on vient de revoir des banderoles
qu'on avait vu sous Jean-Paul II
sont aussi
alors pourquoi pas
on va demander à Jean Sévilla d'ailleurs
comment se passe une procédure de
canonisation puisque vous en êtes engagé
dans une si je puis dire sur celle de
l'impératrice Zita qui a été la dernière
impératrice d'Autriche comment ça se
passe ce genre de démarche il faut il y
a une procédure qui est un petit peu
longue normalement alors on peut faire
des exceptions ça a été fait pour
Jean-Paul Jean-Paul II cet effet pour
Mère Teresa mais normalement il y a une
première enquête qui se passe dans le
diocèse où est morte la personne ça peut
être
déplacer devant diocèse éventuellement
si diocèse ne sent pas capables de
porter cette cause et ses premiers
procès est en procédure César et ensuite
la cause est transférée à Rome à la
corrélation des collées des saints où il
y a un deuxième pensée qui est le procès
romain et ensuite il faut un miracle
pour vérification 2 pour être
canalisation il faut la reconnaissance
des vertus c'est toute une procédure et
puis au final c'est une décision papa de
ce que vous connaissez de ce qui vous a
touché
de l'agide Benoît XVI hot singer Camille
Lalan verduti je pose la question
difficile
est-ce qu'il mériterait est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez soit canoniser
je rappelle que moi il y a nage
notamment je parle sous le contrôle de
Jean Sévilla mais canonisation souvent
était populaire c'était une demande une
demande populaire c'est un acte
démocratique au sein de l'Église
d'autant de canaux qui nous permettent
de pouvoir voilà confier les intentions
et puis savoir qu'on est on est porté
par ces personnes évidemment j'imagine
que la question se posera et puis ceux
qui devront y répondre pour pour y
répondre mais oui il y a quand même une
une
vie remarquable sous certains aspects
aussi bien dans sa jeunesse compliquée
dans cette Allemagne nazie puis tout son
apport théologique et puis effectivement
à la fin de sa vie tous les combats
qu'il a pu mener je sais qu'il y a un
des un des critères c'est d'être c'est
cette d'être un héros de
devoir combattu et je pense qu'il dans
ce cas oui le drapeau bavarois
on va vivre ces images et laisser vivre
ces images donc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici Laura donc les dernières images du
pape Benoît XVI les dernières images
publiques et on voit un certain nombre
de banderoles que l'on avait pas vu
pendant la messe qui sont en train de
d'être montré par les images officielles
du Vatican de la télé du Vatican qui
retransmet donc c'est cette cérémonie on
va retourner justement place
Saint-Pierre retrouvée
Timothée délaime et Jean-Marie Guénon
qui était sur place pendant
toute cette célébration
Timothée peut-être une question avant
que de vous laisser dialoguer avec
Jean-Marie
on n'avait pas entendu beaucoup de
ferveur en tous les cas beaucoup de
d'expressions de de ferveur pendant la
messe en revanche là ce qu'on vient
d'entendre ce qu'on vient de voir c'est
une expression tous les cas dommage et
on a réentendu les cris qu'on avait
entendu au moment d'élection du pape
Benoît XVI
[Musique]
américain qui par sa pensée à marquer le
patrimoine même de l'Église catholique
l'Église catholique c'est c'est pas
seulement des cérémonies c'est aussi
l'interprétation des évangiles donc il y
a un grand travail des théologiens qui
depuis des centaines d'années
travaillent scrutent les textes et
Benoît XV c'était l'un d'eux et il
laisse un patrimoine donc dans l'esprit
des fidèles il y a ces deux dimensions
c'était un saint et c'était un grand
savant d'une certaine manière et
mériterait ce titre de docteur de
l'Église que l'Église donne à ceux qui
précisément ont apporté de manière
notable au patrimoine intellectuel
chrétien et catholiques
un ensemble de connaissances qui
resteront dans l'histoire maintenant ça
c'est dans l'esprit des fidèles et dans
leur cœur est-ce que l'Église officielle
c'est-à-dire la structure de l'église va
décider de cela c'est une autre histoire
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être canonisé
pour être docteur de l'Église il faut
avoir et bien une réputation de santé
mais ça n'est pas du tout nécessaire
mais cela prendra des années parce que
l'Église
prend son temps elle examine tous les
éléments du dossier avant de se lancer
et puis je crois que sur la canonisation
on avait vu lors de la messe des
obsèques de Jean-Paul II en 2005 sur
cette même place ces grandes banderoles
Santos subito tout de suite faites le
faites-en un sein tout de suite
et certains pensent aujourd'hui que
l'église était là un peu vite en
canonisant le pape Jean-Paul II Benoît
16 d'ailleurs avait appuyé cette
canalisation il avait il avait relevé il
avait relevé le délai normal d'attente
pour procéder au procès de canalisations
la procédure localisation donc là on a
cet appel effectivement qui est assez
naturel qui est bienvenue ça fait partie
de la tradition chrétienne
les fidèles sont souvent été bien bien
avant les les prélats dans la
reconnaissance de la santé et ça c'est
le sens des gens maintenant l'église est
prudente et je crois qu'elle est encore
davantage aujourd'hui
cela prendra des années mais en tout cas
je pense que
je m'avance peut-être mais tant pour la
canalisation que pour le docteur de
l'Église le docteur à l'église Benoît
XVI en tout cas a des éléments en tout
cas sa vie son œuvre ont des éléments
objectifs pour que cela puisse un jour
se faire cela prendra du temps néanmoins
alors que le glas de la basilique
Saint-Pierre résonne à nouveau derrière
nous vous l'entendez peut-être derrière
nous Jean-Marie gaynois on parlait des
fidèles ils sont moins nombreux ce n'est
pas comparable par rapport par exemple à
2005 pour Jean-Paul II en revanche
quelque chose et qui m'a qui m'a frappé
c'est cette cette ambiance de
recueillement de prière vous l'avez
probablement vu que moi les gens étaient
vraiment le nez dans les livrets en
train vraiment de suivre la messe très
attentivement et de prier pour le pape
mérite Benoît XV c'est l'une des
caractéristiques de du pontificat du
pape Benoît XV donc 2005 2013 c'est
l'intériorité il a il a vraiment loin du
spectaculaire loin des effets il a il a
cultivé l'intérieur
en lui-même autour de lui et pour les
fidèles on a des souvenirs par exemple
jmji à Madrid devant un million de
personnes de jeunes réunis un silence de
prière totale voilà ça c'était Benoît
XVI parce que c'était un homme de Dieu
profondément enraciné dans la vie
spirituelle dans la contemplation dans
l'étude et aussi dans l'action
évidemment il devait gouverner l'église
mais avant tout sourcer c'était
quelqu'un qui qui était comme capté sur
la source de la prière et cela se sent
aujourd'hui en tout cas ça fait partie
des fruits qui laissent dans cette
génération Benoît XVI on peut appeler
maintenant génération Benoît 16 qui est
marqué à vie par cette appel au fond à
la vie intérieure sur le pape François
une homélie assez courte là aussi mais
lui aussi très recueilli on l'a vu même
assez ému pendant cette messe oui il
était très ému au moment de universel
notamment ce sont des intentions et puis
au moment aussi de la prière finale
quand il implore Dieu d'accueillir le
serviteur qu'il présente comme pape à la
miséricorde de Dieu c'est très
impressionnant de de d'entendre de lire
ces textes et de les entendre dire par
le pape lui-même le Meli était
effectivement courte mais c'est ça
ressemble au pape François qui aime
il recommande en tout cas de ne jamais
dépasser 7 minutes et le texte est
remarquablement dense j'ai beau je lis
professionnelment évidemment beaucoup de
ces textes
on sent un texte très médité il a choisi
lui-même l'Évangile qui raconte la
crucifixion du Christ et le dernier
souffle du Christ et il médite là-dessus
et il médite sur
le mot apparaît trois fois dans le Miss
au dévouement le dévouement priant le
dévouement constant et c'est la note
qu'il attribue au pape Benoît XVI qui
pas voulu être élu pape qui a toujours
rêvé d'être un moine contemplatif dans
un monastère et donc le pape François a
noté cela se dévouement total ce dont
total de lui-même parfois dans
l'incompréhension il est il en parle
dans l'homélie mais justement quel que
soit les incompréhensions que le pape
Benoît a pu subir la compréhension sur
ces décisions à compréhension sur ces
positions théologiques il reste que il a
été un grand serviteur totalement dévoué
totalement donné à sa tâche quel que
soit d'ailleurs quelqu'un en tout cas sa
volonté personnelle il était
disparaissait derrière sa fonction il
était totalement donné à la vocation au
Christ qu'il a voulu servir toute sa vie
et son cercueil de Benoît 16 qui vient
d'être porté à l'intérieur de la
basilique Saint-Pierre qu'est-ce qu'il
va se passer après présent alors le
cercueil qui est en bois de cyprès un
bois un peu qui résiste à l'eau
tradition ici dans l'église va être
ceinturé d'un cercueil en zinc scellé
c'est les officiellement enfin c'est
assez sérieux comme question parce que
l'histoire a montré que certains voulu
s'attribuer des éléments d'un pape pour
pour des histoires de dévotion bon
j'entends parler des détails mais là
donc c'est assez ça paraît résume mais
c'est pas du tout c'est sérieux les
scellés sont posés par deux de
personnalités différentes avec ces
notariés enfin tout ça et comme tout un
petit protocole puis un autre cercueil
pour pour le mettre dedans la crypte ou
il est il va être enterré cette crypte
en fait elle est au premier sous-sol de
la basilique et là déjà accueilli Jean
23 elle a accueilli Jean-Paul II qui en
ont été extraits au moment où ils ont
été canonisés en 2014 et là on les a
exposés ils sont dans la basilique quand
vous entrez un basique il y a des hôtels
où on peut voir Jean 23 et le pape
Jean-Paul II et tous les fidèles peuvent
venir prier devant eux les gens
évidemment la pourront descendre dans la
crypte ça s'était produit de façon
spectaculaire après les de Jean-Paul II
en 2005 2006 2007 il y avait toujours
des queues des gens qui venaient prier
descendait dans cette crypte pour prier
ce pape assez étroite par ailleurs oui
mais on peut vraiment il y a de la place
pour pour payer mais en tout cas c'est
un lieu ça va devenir un lieu de de
dévotion je pense que comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure sur cette place comme on
a vu le le lien finalement assez très
intime très spirituel de beaucoup avec
le pape Benoît XVI un lien spirituel
encore une fois qui n'est pas dans
l'extravagance qui n'est pas extraverti
qui est dans l’intériorité et bien il va
se continuer dans la prière parce que
c'est aussi une tradition chrétienne et
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que l'histoire
de la Santé a commencé c'est parce que
des fidèles sont allés prier sur la
tombe de quelqu'un qu'ils estimait saint
que petit à petit au fil des ans au fil
des ans l'église alors finit par
reconnaître cette santé et bien ça se
rejoue à chaque fois une grande
personnalité comme celle que l'Église
vient de perdre
des gens vont continuer à le prier ça
fait partie de la tradition chrétienne
on prie pour lui on prier avec lui en
considérant qu'il est près de Dieu c'est
vraiment la théologie chrétienne qu'il
peut intercéder pour des gens et je sais
très respectable certains n'y croient
pas mais d'autres y croient et c'est en
tout cas un grand un très grand croyant
que l'Église vient enterré aujourd'hui
voilà merci beaucoup Jean-Marie guenois
pour cette analyse et alors que vous le
voyez Vincent les fidèles les dizaines
de milliers de fidèles qui sont en train
de quitter la place Saint-Pierre
toujours dans cette dans cette ambiance
il faut imaginer un des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui sont en train
et bien d'évacuer les lieux toujours
dans cette ambiance de silence de prière
et de recueillement une dernière
question Timothée pour pour Jean-Marie
je m'en excuse auprès des internautes
parce qu'elle va être posée deux fois du
coup mais qu'est-ce que Jean-Marie qui a
quand même l'habitude maintenant des
enterrements pontificaux enfin c'est son
deuxième qu'il couvre et de toutes ces
cérémonies et ces événements qu'est-ce
qu'il a marqué le plus aujourd'hui
oui Jean-Marie une question dans
l'internaute du Figaro qu'est-ce qui
vous a marqué le plus aujourd'hui
quels sont difficiles je remercie celui
qui l'a posé parce que effectivement
j'ai eu beaucoup d'expérience similaires
j'ai
personnellement pu suivre de très près
le pape Benoît sèche je l'ai connu avant
qu'il ne soit pas je l'ai suivi dans
beaucoup de voyages
[Musique]
ce qui me frappe c'est finalement
cette sobriété de ses obsèques et aussi
finalement il y a pas foule il y a de la
foule évidemment de personnes on va le
savoir tout à l'heure exactement
peut-être 60 000 peu importe justement
il n'y a pas foule et c'est un très
caractéristique de ce pape Benoît XVI
pas quelqu'un qui a qui a justement
battu la campagne pour attirer il
considérait que le christianisme était
justement une religion
à laquelle on adherait librement il a
beaucoup insisté là-dessus il a beaucoup
insisté sur la foi et la raison bien sûr
mais il a beaucoup insisté sur la
liberté intérieure ça rejoint d'ailleurs
le même schéma de l'intériorité et donc
bien sûr ça fait longtemps qu'il est
qu'il est qu'il a quitté le pont de fica
une dizaine d'années on est en pleine
semaine ici à Rome en plus une semaine
de vacances les Romains ne sont pas ici
sont dans leur famille parce que demain
une grande fête c'est là où les familles
offrent les cadeaux enfin le c'est le
deuxième Noël en Italie donc les Romains
sont pas forcément rendez vous mais ça
n'a pas d'importance parce que le
message de Benoît XVI n'est pas dans la
quantité dans les chiffres dans les
données justement il est dans
l'intérieurité dans l'essentiel et ce
n'est pas du tout un pape de la quantité
mava de la qualité
voilà Vincent pour cette réponse de
Jean-Marie gaynorain si beaucoup
Timothée et effectivement c'était pas un
internaute c'était moi qui l'a posé mais
j'espère que Jean-Marie me pardonnera et
on vous retrouve encore
quelques instants et puis tout au long
de la journée pour voir également
comment les Français qui sont venus sur
place ont vécu ces instants et pourquoi
ils sont venus on y reviendra merci
je reviens sur un certain nombre de
choses qui ont été dites par Jean-Marie
guenon en continu bien sûr de suivre de
recevoir de commenter ces images qui
nous parviennent du Vatican et notamment
dès qu'on les a celles de l'inhumation
si le Vatican les films et les transmets
sur cette question de d'être docteur ou
pas de l'église on va
Jean-Marie guenois vient d'expliquer en
quoi ça consistait
est-ce que à votre avis il le mérite je
pose la question différemment au Catrice
est-ce que c'est pas un peu surfé cette
réputation de grand intellectuel il a
effectivement tout le monde le dit des
grandes qualités de pédagogue une grande
culture mais qu'elle percée en
conceptuelle il l'a fait au cours de sa
vie quels sont les les apports vraiment
par de nombreux paradigmatique qui
permettrait d'en faire un docteur de
l'Église ou ce grand théologien dans
tout le monde parle alors on voudrait
plutôt poser la question un professeur
de théologique à moi-même mais enfin
pour la perception que j'en ai
il y a un texte de Benoît cesse du cadre
Seeger parce que du temps de son
pontificat il est peu de temps il y a ça
trilogie sur Jésus qui est un livre
fondamental mais qui à mon avis il avait
déjà dû penser qu'on se voit avant
d'être les papes
il y a des il y a des textes qui sont
tout à fait fondamentaux
maintenant je m'aperçois que c'est un
très grand penseur il a nourri ma foi il
m'a il m'a il son apport à l'église et
considérable donc qu'un ancien
adversaire je mets du carlinger et ce
propos-là ça veut dire qu'il y a une
pensée de de de Benoît XVI qui dépasse
le les polémiques intimes enfin interne
ou catholicisme
sur ce qu'on a justement dit beaucoup
autour de de Racinger sur les rapports
entre la foi et la raison on a beaucoup
parlé de cette expression en quoi ça
consiste quel a été
l'oeuvre de Red singer dans ce domaine
qu'est-ce qu'il a qu'est-ce qu'il a
voulu faire
voulu on était on est quand même une
période du Sud de la spécialité du
spectacle du tiers de manière le grand
Saint Jean-Paul II a été un homme de la
société du spectacle mais il l'a mise au
service du christianisme bon c'était pas
pour sa propre personne
et et beaucoup et les générations
catholiques sont souvent aussi dans dans
l'émotion une approche de la de la
région qui est très très léger bio
participé de ce satmosphère là voilà
donc ce qui n'est pas malsain soit mais
ce que
le carnaval de figure a voulu rappeler
avec Jean-Paul II et puis lancer qu'il
faut a raison de Jean-Paul II est à 80%
écrite par le Canadien c'est que la foi
est ancrée dans la raison c'est à dire
que ça n'est pas simplement
l'élimination d'abord il y a une
révélation il y a une histoire il y a un
travail structurel qu'on peut faire il y
a un travail
d'analyse et et c'est fondé en raison
c'est la croix en Dieu ce n'est pas une
illumination il y a on peut on peut
définir qu'est-ce que c'est que la Foire
du et la théologie est une est une
science est une science pas au sens
d'ailleurs que c'est des scientifiques
qui sont meilleurs en théologie que
littéraires de philosophie
expérience à faire
Camille Alan barduc Guillaume de
tanouarne qui écrit qui a répondu aux
questions de Renan Planchon lundi après
la
sur le lendemain de la mort de Benoît
XVI finalement l'apport de Benoît XVI
le couple froid raison c'est que
d'habitude
les gens disent il faut comprendre avant
de croire lui dit d'abord on croit et
après
tout ça qui va permettre de comprendre
alors question est-ce que vous dans
votre rapport à Benoît XVI c'est le
c'est l'expérience que vous avez fait
mieux compris je sais pas si c'est en
rapport avec Benoit 16 mais en tout cas
moi je fais l'expérience que
effectivement la fois et la confiance
marche main dans la main et que et que
il y a un pari à faire c'est le pari de
la confiance mais donc du coup de la foi
mais il y a une vraie cohérence dans
tout ce qui est dans tout ce que
l'Église nous enseigne quel que soit
l'angle d'attaque ou de perception ou
d'études que l'on puisse prendre au bout
du bout c'est ça reste un tout cohérent
et c'est pour ça que ça fait appel à la
raison
mais la foi c'est quelque chose quand
même qui est un don c'est pas parce
qu'on veut avoir la foi qu'on l'aura
elle ne s'impose pas donc il y a quand
même quelque chose qu'on qu'on reçoit je
sais pas si c'est tout à fait lié à
Benoît XV mais en tout cas c'est ce que
moi j'ai reçu de de l'enseignement de
l'Église question Bruno Joubert la fois
elle a raison c'est au cœur d'une des
premières polémiques qui
a éclaboussé le début du pontificat de
c'est la fameuse politique polémique de
racisme il explique nous en substance
nous catholique nous utilisons la foi la
raison pour pour la foi nous
n'excommunions pas la raison et il cite
à ce moment-là un empereur byzantin qui
il met ça en opposition avec l'islam en
citant un empereur byzantin qui dit qu'a
apporté qu'a apporté le Mahomet il a
apporté la violence on en a on a
beaucoup reproché à Benoît XVI cette
phrase j'ai une question là encore un
peu provocatrice mais est-ce que les
événements qui ont suivi et l'émotion
mais les événements qui ont suivi
cette déclaration en particulier dans
certains pays musulmans notamment au
Pakistan qui ont été marqués par des
violences n'ont pas donné précisément
raison à Benoît XVI
oui alors sur cette histoire là d'abord
je crois qu'il y a un merveilleux
exemple de grandes manipulation moderne
de l'opinion de mauvaises réception par
les opinions ignorantes par des gens qui
n'ont pas lu qui ont entendu dire et
donc c'est pas étonnant qu'il y a eu
cette espèce de Bronka autour de autour
de la faire de Ratisbonne tout ce que
Jean Benoît XV avait dit c'était que
parce qu'il avait pas repris les propos
à son compte il avait juste cité
l'empereur Manuel de Paléologue en
disant voilà ce qu'il disait lui qui
vivait confronté à des musulmans on est
à une période où déjà l'Empire byzantin
est très menacé et à ce moment-là
il dit Benoît XVI il faut condamner
la violence qui s'exerce pour obliger à
aller vers la foi et là évidemment on
retrouve toute l'histoire d'une partie
de de la conquête musulmane on retrouve
toute la relation on voit aujourd'hui
dans certains problèmes d'iodisme sur la
conversion forcée donc tout ça on peut
comprendre que dans l'instant mal dit
enfin mal compris
exclure exploitée par des gens qui
trouvaient là une brèche et puis donner
la querelle c'est mais c'était une
exagération complète et c'était
exactement le contraire justement du
message de Benoît nous voulons que la
foi soit
issue de notre propre libre arbitre ce
qui frappe dans cette polémique encore
une fois c'est que Benoît XVI les propos
de la saison était condamnés y compris
dans les milieux diplomatique y compris
dans les milieux de la diplomatie du
Saint Siège
par manque de tac qui manque
d'intelligence des situations etc etc
mais on n'a pas tellement entendu les
autorités
à ce moment là condamner les violences
qui ont suivi ces propos alors c'était
terminérant toute l'ambiguïté là il faut
venir sur ce que Benoît XV a fait lui
après ça parce que le paradoxe de cette
affaire c'est que ça a peut-être poussé
Benoît 16 à porter plus d'attention à la
question du dialogue avec l'islam même
s'il faut être dit tout de suite que
y compris au moment où il a quitté le
pontificat
le rapprochement avec les musulmans
n'était pas complet qu'est-ce qu'a fait
Benoît XVI il a il a reçu ce rappel le
roi d'Arabie Saoudite tout de suite
après cette cette affaire il était en
Turquie et surtout il a nommé le
cardinal torrent qui était l'ancien
ministre d'affaires étrangères cardinal
français extrêmement compétent à la tête
du du
de l'instrument
du Vatican qui s'occupe de la relation
avec l'islam et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que
le cardinal torrent a tout de suite vu
que le dialogue avec l'islam ne pouvait
porter dans l'immédiat que sur ce qu'il
a appelé la régulation
juridico-politique c'est-à-dire on peut
pas entrer en discussion théologique
c'est trop compliqué ça nous mènera
nulle part ça ne fera que des
antagonistes justement parce qu'il y a
une relation une
relation à la raison qui n'est pas la
même en revanche on peut discuter d'une
manière
concrète pragmatique sur ce que comment
nous nous y prenons et c'était très
intéressant de voir que très
discrètement il y a eu des dialogues qui
ont été menés par exemple avec l'islam
chiite en Iran et là le courant passait
facilement parce qu'on avait deux clergé
qui se parlaient donc voilà je pense que
il faut pas trop exagérer cette affaire
ça plutôt été une source de dialogue
qu'autre chose est-ce qu'il y a pas
certains pays ou bien certaines
tendances internationales notamment les
néoconservateurs israéliens certains
néoconservateurs américains certains
milieux israéliens qui eux
ont pu entre guillemets apprécier ces
propos et cette polémique probablement
probablement y a-t-il des gens qui ont
besoin de souffler sur les braises
peut-être y a-t-il des gens qui sont
convaincus qui a un antagonisme
fondamental entre l'Islam et le
christianisme ou le judaïsme c'est en
tout cas c'est pas ma conviction à moi
personnellement mais je suis pas là pour
l'exprimer je pense que c'est
en tout cas pas la conviction de
l'Église catholique ça c'est très clair
l'Église catholique et catholique et ça
veut dire universelle donc par
définition à l'église cherche à
s'adresser à des hommes de toute
provenance et donc c'est évident que
l'Église ne peut s'interdire aucun
dialogue avec qui que ce soit ça serait
contraire principal de sa mission un
événement comme celui-là j'y reviens
puisque on parlait justement
les dimensions diplomatiques a dit que
Benoît XVI n'avait pas n'avait pas une
expérience en tous les cas enfin un
bilan diplomatique très fort
est-ce que un événement comme celui-là
quand même aujourd'hui on voyait
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure les les
quelques prélats saluer les autorités
présentes notamment on les a pas cités
le président François Steiner et ola
Schulz le président et chancelier
allemand est-ce que
cette
séquences là sont importantes pour pour
les ambassadeurs pour les chefs d'État
c'est séquences informelles moi j'ai eu
ce sentiment là je voudrais pas rentrer
tôt dans les détails mais à une occasion
où j'étais sur place j'ai reçu un
premier ministre et un ministre des
Affaires étrangères français qui
venaient pour une cérémonie du type de
celle que nous venons de voir et comme
il faut arriver très en avant dans ces
cérémonies les diplomates sont placés
vous l'avez vu tout près mais ça suppose
d'arriver bien avec beaucoup d'avance il
a fallu que j'embarque entre guillemets
tout ce petit monde en les faisant lever
un peu tôt et la réflexion d'un de ces
messieurs a été de venir mais enfin
pourquoi nous fait-on arriver c'est tout
qu'on va s'ennuyer quoi en gros or ce
qui m'a amus c'est qu'ensuite pendant
les 45 minutes qu'on a passé sur cette
esplanade
c'était une mini ONU et et notamment un
de mes deux messieurs qui m'avait fait
la remarque n'a cessé de galoper de
l'Inde vers l'eau de l'eau de Merlin il
y avait la vice-président des États-Unis
il y avait la chancelière allemande il y
avait tout le monde était sur le plateau
entre guillemets et donc là c'était une
occasion formidable de mesurer ce que
c'est que la capacité du Saint Siège a
regrouper des gens venus du monde entier
le dialogue nous venons de parler et de
permettre ses contacts totalement
informel mais qui compte tellement dans
la vie internationale c'était des
contacts en l'occurrence auquel vous
faites allusion qui qui était juste des
contacts entre guillemets mondain ou
bien est-ce que il y avait certaines
questions qui étaient traitées certains
dossiers qui étaient noués je ne peux
pas imaginer que lorsqu'un ministre
français ou un premier ministre
rencontre un de leurs alter ego
Europe1 américain
vice-présidents américains ils étaient
juste à leur dire comment vas-tu je
pense qu'il y a ils ont toujours un
sujet très
utile à faire avancer les choses et en
ce sens même si il y avait peu de temps
dans ces discussions encore que
certaines est plus durer un peu assez
longtemps c'est justement un moment où
la conversation peut être libre et
approfondie le Vatican est encore une
puissance l'essentiel est encore une
puissance diplomatique oui d'abord parce
que
constatons que après les États-Unis
c'est auprès du Vatican qui est le plus
d'ambassade qui sont à crédités donc ça
ça donne une idée de l'universalité
ensuite c'est une puissance diplomatique
parce que le Vatican est répandu sur la
terre entière donc il a des informations
des possibilités d'action qui lui
remontent de partout et surtout dans des
coins où parfois les diplomaties
traditionnelles ne sont plus parce que
les pays sont en pro à la guerre parce
que c'est trop difficile en revanche là
où il ne faut pas se méprendre c'est le
fait que la diplomatie vaticale n'est
pas destinée à faire avancer les
intérêts matériels économiques
politiques d'un état mais à faire les
intérêts de la défense de l'église
l'Église universelle mais aussi l'église
là où elle se trouve donc en fait la
diplomatie vaticale vise d'abord et
avant tout à gérer la relation d'une
église particulière l'église chinoise
l'église américaine avec les autorités
du pays en question
dernier une autre question quelle est
l'intérêt pour vous ambassadeur quelle a
été l'intérêt pour vous on va savoir
d'être là en plus bien sûr d'admirer les
splendeurs de la ville éternelle je
crois que c'est le sentiment justement
d'être le témoin en un endroit précis
qui est Rome d'une universalité qui
s'exprime comme elle peut s'exprimer à
New York ou que s'exprimer à Genève dans
des places qui sont multilatérales et de
se rendre compte qu'à travers ces
gens-là qui sont tous présents on peut
avoir des informations et des actions
sur l'ensemble de la planète
le club Le Figaro international lundi
reviendra sur cette question Bruno
Joubert avec votre prédécesseur
d'ailleurs Stanislas
je et ce sera effectivement très
intéressant parce que c'est animé par
l'excellent Philippe génie et on
reviendra également sur toutes ces
questions mais merci beaucoup de nous
avoir justement
repréciser ça parce que on sous-estime
finalement la puissance diplomatique de
petites institutions comme le Vatican
comme l'ONU également l'institution
internationale comme la FAO ou l'UNESCO
mais qui permettent justement d'être des
lieux un petit peu neutres où peuvent
avoir des un certain nombre de de
discussion on peut faire avancer
discrètement à certains membres de
sujets puisqu'on a compris que chez les
diplomates paraît-il il vaut mieux
parfois paraître bête que bavard mais
vous n'étiez ni l'un ni l'autre
c'était en effet ce que disait quelqu'un
il vaut mieux être avoir l'air bête
qu'avoir l'air comme on dirait suffisant
une question avant de on va bientôt
clôturer cette cette
édition cette émission spéciale mais
d'abord on a parlé donc des continuités
des ruptures entre les deux papes est-ce
que comme on peut l'entendre parfois
pardon le casser l'ambiance mais Benoît
XVI n'a pas assisté
lors de sa renonciation à moins ça
renonciation après ça renonciation à
l'effondrement de son œuvre je prends
deux exemples d'abord son oeuvre ça m'a
tendu aux traditionnalisme et ensuite on
y reviendra dans un deuxième temps
justement ce qu'il avait fait au niveau
eucuménico diplomatique sur la question
avec les traditionnalistes on vient
d'apprendre en tout cas c'est
l'hebdomadaire
Spiegel allemand et cité par
l'hebdomadaire français famille
chrétienne qui le révèle ce matin mon
Seigneur gunshine qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure dit que le Pape a eu énormément
de peine en lisant les en prenant
connaissance des mesures que le pape
François avait pris à l'encontre des
traditionnalistes oui c'est une
interview que
c'est herican a donné un journal et moi
j'ai visionné cette cette interview il
dit en allemand
que
l'encylique traditionnelle scoustaque
qui revenait sur un
donc annulant la liberté laissée à
l'ancien rythme à briser le coeur du
pape je pense oui c'est l'idée de la
réconciliation des deux rites l'idée
l'intégration
cette idée que un rythme ne peut pas
devenir totalement interdit il y a
nourri la foi pendant des siècles de
fidèles ne peut pas devenir totalement
église et fondamentale chez chez Benoît
16 et pas seulement pour se réconcilier
avec les traditionnistes les personnes
mais pour des raisons de théologie
fondamentale c'est parce qu'il y a une
unité de toujours cette idée qui a une
unité dans dans la vie de l'Église
l'Église c'est la continuité donc ce qui
a été sacré à un moment donné ne veut
pas devenir interdit même si ça n'a même
plus le même place donc ça je pense que
là il y a une rupture fondamentale qui a
du certainement coûté à Benoît XV c'est
évident et qui qui reste un problème qui
est un problème qui est très ouvert pour
une partie du catholicisme en tout cas
on va on va y revenir on va aller à Rome
retrouver Timothée de qui est sur place
Timothée vous êtes avec un jeune
français qui a assisté à la cérémonie
absolument Vincent je suis avec la BU de
franc-lieu des Missionnaires de la
miséricorde divine vous me confiez à
l'instant que vous êtes arrivé ce matin
à 6h du matin pour venir suivre cette
messe de funérailles du papeet Mérite
Benoît 16 pourquoi c'était si important
pour vous d'être là ce matin et bien
d'abord je suis de la génération du pape
Benoît XVI c'est-à-dire que moi quand
j'étais jeune j'ai connu Jean-Paul II
assez vieux donc pour moi Benoit sai
c'était un pape jeune je me souviens
très bien de son élection c'est la
première élection d'un pape pour moi et
je me souviens on était devant la
télévision tous en famille et je m'étais
dit et bien c'est la fin des problèmes
dans l'église
et alors finalement qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui vous ressort là de cette
de cette journée vous qui avez vécu
cette cette messe de funéraire qu'est-ce
qui vous a frappé et bien pour moi venir
à Rome d'abord c'est toujours
venir près du pape venir près de
Saint-Pierre donc devenir plus
catholique d'une certaine manière donc
ce qui me frappe toujours et c'était
encore le cas aujourd'hui c'est cette
foule de toute peuple race et nations
qui viennent parce que leur pape c'est
leur père leur pape c'est leur pasteur
et du coup qui viennent rendre un
dernier hommage à celui qui les attend
marqués on a parlé un petit peu de cette
atmosphère assez particulière parce que
ça reste une messe d'enterrement et
pourtant les mines ne sont pas
particulièrement tristes il y a presque
une espèce de joie de ferveur comment
est-ce que vous expliquez cela
je pense que tout le monde sait que
Benoît XV avait probablement hâte de
rejoindre le Père donc pour nous c'était
à la fois triste bien sûr parce qu'on
perdait un père et puis en même temps
nous sommes heureux je crois c'est vrai
qui puisse être au ciel c'est ce que
nous pensons en tout cas là vous vous
reprenez vous reprenez l'avion vous
repartez en France vous êtes venus
vraiment exprès pour cette pour cette
baisse ah non je ne reprends pas du tout
l'avion je reprends la voiture parce que
je suis parti à 22h hier nous avons
roulé toute la nuit et nous repartons
dans trois heures en voiture en effet
direction la France direction Toulon
direction Toulon voilà en tous les cas
pour cette cette réaction de de la bille
Hugues de franlieux donc missionnaire de
la miséricorde divine qui reprend sa
voiture d'ici quelques heures à
direction Toulon bien entendu à tous les
internautes qui sont à Toulon et dans le
sud-est de la France merci beaucoup
Timothée vous revenez nous voir pour
d'autres témoignages
une question
je vais revenir avec vous Camille
justement sur ce restera de cette
journée et puis peut-être la suite on va
y revenir sur la ce qu'on disait tous
les cas la question qui est posée sur en
tout cas l'effondrement d'une partie de
son œuvre de son vivant est-ce que tout
ce qui a été entrepris
Bruno Joubert sur
le rapprochement avec l'orthodoxie et à
travers ça avec la Russie
ne s'est pas effondré avec la guerre en
Ukraine
non non je ne crois pas que ce soit
effondré vraiment avec parce que tous
les antagonistes à l'intérieur même de
l'orthodoxie et et entre les
Ukrainiens les catholiques ukrainiens et
les
je pense que le monde orthologue c'est
de toute façon complexe divisé
très sourcilleux sur son indépendance
chaque église donc le travail qui a été
fait sur le fond le rapprochement avec
le patriarcat communique à
Constantinople qui va rester on a
rapproché beaucoup de choses il y a une
confiance qui s'est créée on précise
d'ailleurs que le patriarcat de
Constantinople
en revanche avec Moscou
on voit bien que là en ce moment ça va
très mal et que ça efface non pas Benoît
16 mais ça efface les progrès que
François avait consacré avec sa fameuse
rencontre avec Kyril Cuba qui était
censé apporter la preuve que la démarche
de rapprochement avec Moscou c'est
possible ce qu'on note c'est quand même
que
le l'orthodoxie moscovite enfin russe
moi je suis pas du tout un spécialiste
et quand même très très inféodé à la
dimension nationale politique et que par
conséquent le dialogue dans ces
conditions
particulièrement d'une guerre devient
quasi quasi impossible du moins tant que
on a affaire à des gens qui ne font pas
le départ entre leur pays leur foi c'est
un peu de ça dont il s'agit dans la
question et encore une fois pour les
autres
orthodoxes je ne sais pas les
différentes sensibilités qui peut
s'exprimer actuellement autour de ça
mais ce que je note c'est que
pour ce qui est de l'Ukraine même
l'église autocéphale
orthodoxe est en train de prendre
l'avantage avec des certainement des
déchets moins terribles et on a
l'impression au contraire que
ceux qui sont référents de à Rome
les catholiques de rite orthodoxes grecs
qui sont en Ukraine cela
sont moins ostracisés donc il y a des
mouvements qui sont en train de se faire
je crois que de tout ça de cette
complexité farante et de cette tension
qui n'est de la guerre
renaîtra un dialogue possible un peu
plus tard je parle avec Moscou puisque
avec les autres j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'est pas rompu au contraire
on va retourner dans un instant à Rome
avec Timothée délame qui est avec
d'autres Français sur place Camille vous
irez vous recueillir sur la tombe
c'est une excellente idée et c'est
tout à la fin non mais à la fin de la
messe là quand on se réveille il y a
deux moments qui vont un peu saisi c'est
le la bénédiction du cercueil avec avec
l'eau bénite et le goupillon et puis ces
applaudissements et là je me suis dit ah
ouais c'est vrai ça y est c'est la fin
il y a quelque chose qui est qui qui
saisit un petit peu et j'aimerais en
fait oui je me rends compte que
j'aimerais rendre hommage et me
recueillir comment
un immense merci pour pour le don de sa
vie pour le pour tout ce qu'il a fait et
pour et pour Dieu et pour nous enfin
voilà c'est c'est un don total et il a
porté jusqu'au bout et dont on bénéficie
donc ce sera un immense merci
sera-t-il béatifié et canonisé comme ses
prédécesseurs nous demandent Jean le
mérite-t-il demande de manchard
effectivement c'est toute la question
qu'on se pose depuis en tous les cas la
fin de cette cérémonie on va retourner à
Rome retrouver Timothée délai mais
peut-être c'est une question qui peut
poser au français qui sont avec lui
oui je suis avec deux Français qui sont
effectivement venus exprès pour cette
pour cette messe de funérailles du pape
François Vincent roux me demande à
l'instant c'est vrai qu'on a entendu des
centres to subito à la fin de la messe
le pape Benoît XVI doit il doit être
proclamé ça
personnellement je dirais que chaque
chose en son temps le temps des
funérailles le temps de peut-être
faire ce qu'il y a peut-être pas été
tellement fait pendant son plus
fortificat s'intéresser profondément
c'était logique en nombre et ensuite
laisser le docteur de l'Église peut-être
parler et peut-être le sang on verra
vous êtes venus à exprès depuis la
France pour cette messe de funérailles
pourquoi est-ce que c'était important
pour vous d'être là aujourd'hui on est
de la génération Benoît XVI moi j'ai eu
la chance de le voir aux Invalides à
Paris en 2008 au JMJ en 2011 à Madrid ça
a été des moments marquants dans dans ma
construction et c'est vrai que c'est un
pape qui qui m'a beaucoup touché par son
humilité par par ses paroles justes par
sa douceur et donc c'est vrai qu'en tant
que chrétien c'était important pour moi
d'être présent place Saint-Pierre
aujourd'hui même question pour vous
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé chez ce chez
ce pape Benoît XVI
personnellement je dirais que c'est
cet amour de l'église mais l'Église
vraiment entendu dans son sens universel
complet qu'on pouvait voir aujourd'hui
qui réunissait des gens de toute nation
de toutes conditions on va dire donc on
est certes à Rome aujourd'hui mais il y
avait des Européens des Sud-Américains
les Africains des gens venus de partout
et même de toute l'Église des orthodoxes
des protestants et c'est ce que j'ai
particulièrement aimé chez spa c'est cet
amour de l'Église c'est amour du Christ
et
par sa tendresse et son humilité
chercher à faire l'unité et aller
au-delà des frontières qui peuvent
diviser les chrétiens parfois vous me
disiez à l'instant que vous aviez la
chance d'être particulièrement bien
placé vous êtes arrivés tôt ce matin à
quelle heure êtes-vous arrivés et quel
était on va dire l'atmosphère au milieu
des fidèles
nous sommes arrivés il était 6h du matin
alors je dirais que tout le monde était
pressé en fait de pouvoir être le mieux
passé sans doute pour pour voir le pape
une dernière fois voir aussi le pape
François qui était présent
je dirais qu'il y avait une atmosphère
de gratitude de reconnaissance et de
recueillement c'est quelque chose qui
vous a frappé également et le
recueillement c'était c'était vraiment
l'image de des moments que j'avais pu
vivre avec le pape Benoît XV c'était des
moments je me souviens de l'adoration à
Madrid en 2011 c'était très très fort
très très émouvant très recueilli et
vraiment pour toutes les pour tous les
catholiques qui étaient présents ce
matin c'était un vrai moment de
recueillement et de de grâce aussi pour
pour le pontificat de de du pape Benoît
XV donc on a on a pu rendre grâce ce
matin tous ensemble
voilà Vincent pour ces pour ces deux
jeunes Français qui sont rendus donc à
cette messe de funérailles qui ont pris
leur billet d'avion me disait-il
aussitôt après avoir appris le décès de
Benassi c'est ça le 31 décembre c'est en
fait c'est assez simple on s'est
retrouvé un réveillon et on s'est dit au
bout de 10 minutes on va à Rome et
c'était fixé à partir de ce moment-là et
deux jours après on prenait nos billets
on arrivait à Rome après et ils sont là
voilà Vincent pour cette pour cette
réaction c'est une résolution qu'ils ont
pris pour 2023 et qu'ils ont tenu ils
ont de la chance ça n'arrive pas à tout
le monde merci beaucoup Timothée pour
ces témoignages on va bientôt conclure
alors que on voit encore les dernières
images depuis Rome de la place
Saint-Pierre qui est en train de se
vider
je vous cite dans l'église le cardinal
Ratzinger mène la bataille des idées
c'est ce que vous écriviez lundi
gagné la team perdu
le match n'est pas terminé donc on va
voir moi je
tendentiellement je pense que il garde
des atouts considérables je veux dire ça
son influence
dans dans le monde catholique est un
monde qui est dans le monde occidental
et dans le monde de repère occidental et
en France se réduit numériquement si
vous voulez
mais en même temps se maintient à se
reconstitue sur des bases qui sont des
bases sur tout spirituelle
et bien son influence reste considérable
et je veux dire le jeune clergé
d'aujourd'hui est très marqué il a été
par le Portugal Benoit 16 il était aussi
par par ceux de Jean-Paul II parce que
Jean-Paul II c'est comme pas si loin
c'est pas c'est pas le 19e siècle
donc son influence est très importante
et et et
pour moi mais là évidemment je mêle un
peu le temps croyant moi-même je mêle un
peu la position du journaliste écrivain
du croyant mais je crois que vous
demande juste d'accord des fois et
raison oui
je sais cette cette question sur cette
primauté pour lui de la prière de la
contemplation et pour moi quelque chose
de fondamental sur lequel se reconstruit
se reconstitue des forces qui sont sans
doute souterraines mais qui sont très
importantes dans dans le catholicisme
aujourd'hui
est-ce que les ambassadeurs comme vous
qui étaient du
temps de Benoît XVI ont été marqués par
sa personnalité question subsidiaire
Bruno Joubert quel empreinte il laissait
il a laissé sur les deux chefs d'État
français qui l'ont vu et qui l'ont enfin
en tous les cas qui était en poste quand
il durant son pontificat Jacques Chirac
vous étiez vous n'étiez pas forcément en
poste à ce moment-là mais en tous les
cas vous étiez en poste Nicolas Sarkozy
et de François Hollande sur ce point
précis j'ai pas de confidence de leur
part mais je crois savoir que pour
Nicolas Sarkozy il éprouvait véritable
proximité
intérêt pour la personne de Benoît il va
chercher à le voir il l'avait rencontré
il a cherché à le revoir il avait un
lien me dit-on assez
peut-être pas régulier mais il avait un
lien personnel avec lui et donc c'est
très curieux parce que ces deux hommes
que dans l'image on pourrait opposer en
réalité il y avait certainement quelque
chose pour François Hollande
j'ai assisté à la visite
que le Président de la République a fait
au pape
c'était plus tard c'était pas avec ce
papier et donc avec Benoît XVI je veux
dire et donc je ne sais pas quels
étaient les sentiments qu'ils pouvaient
porter au pape si on avait d'ailleurs
simplement ce que j'ai vu que c'est
qu'en effet il avait été assez difficile
de préparer
un peu de difficulté avec la fête bon
mais du coup on ne l'a pas vu à Rome ça
a posé des questions ils se sont
beaucoup interrogés dans les équipes qui
l'entouraient savoir s'il allait venir
si vous s'il était nécessaire qu'il va
et puis finalement
bon les choses ne se sont pas faites
et du coup
je n'ai pas là dessus d'autres alors
quand on est parti de votre question bon
moi j'étais j'ai dit un mot de ça au
tout début de l'émission mais vous
l'avez vu après ça renonciation après
non personne ne l'a vu et même pour vous
faire un aveu j'ai cherché
à le mettre en contact avec une
personnalité française importante qui
souhaitait le être reçu et
en dépit de tout il s'y refusé en
exprimant bien le souci qu'il avait de
s'en tenir la parole qu'il avait donné
de ne plus se mêler il a vu quand même
des il a vu même des Français parce
qu'on en a reçu un cristal Christophe
Ducasse qui nous a raconté ça mais il
voulait plus rencontrer de personnalités
politiques qui auraient pu donner
l'impression qu'il cherchait à porter
ombrage à son successeur et ça c'était
très très important et je trouve de sa
part évidemment une preuve
supplémentaire de la grandeur d'arme de
cet homme
qu'est-ce qui vous reste de Benoît XV
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai bien aimé ces textes voici quel
est notre Dieu Jésus de Nazareth des
choses assez concrètes enfin
simple d'accès et qui nous élève donc
voilà moi aujourd'hui je me dis que j'ai
sous les sous les yeux et dans ma
bibliothèque tout un tout un trésor à
approfondir on va vous donner une
biographie en juste après le direct pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir compléter
Timothée délaime à Rome on fait un
dernier tour avec vous qu'est-ce qu'on
retient de cette matinée que va-t-il se
passer maintenant
et bien Vincent on retiendra cette messe
comme jeu comme je l'ai dit plusieurs
fois très recueilli très brillante et
puis ces personnes qui sont venues du
monde entier d'ailleurs on voyait pas
forcément cela pendant la messe mais là
on voit alors malheureusement vous
pouvez pas le voir à la caméra mais
certains drapeaux il y a un drapeau
français il y a également un drapeau
portugais voilà quelques quelques
drapeaux une ambiance recueillie une
ambiance également avec évidemment
beaucoup on entend beaucoup parler
italien mais on entend également parler
espagnol dont on parlait français on en
parle on entend parler évidemment
allemand également la place Saint-Pierre
qui se vit à vitesse grand V les fidèles
sont maintenant maintenant quittés
quitter les lieux avec évidemment encore
pas mal de va-et-vient ici et ce qui va
se passer maintenant et bien le pape
émérite Benoit 16 qui va être enterré ça
cela va se passer pardon au sein à
l'intérieur des grottes vaticales dans
la crypte de la de la basilique
Saint-Pierre une cérémonie qui n'est pas
ouverte aux médias ni au public ni au
fidèle évidemment les lieux seraient
bien trop petit voilà pour pour la suite
de des événements ici ici ici à Rome les
images chantourner par le ciel on les
récupère à elles sont retrouvées bien
entendu sur le site du Figaro merci
beaucoup Timothée et puis on continue à
vous suivre tout au long de l'après-midi
sur
cet hommage les hommages qui vont être
rendus à Benoît XVI sur la question des
miracles parce que le débat a commencé
sur le chat et bien Jean nous Jean qui
n'est pas Sévilla nous rappelle que
c'est il faut des miracles mais genre
c'est via va nous le confirmer un
miracle il en faut deux pour une
canalisation voilà
Christian nous dit le miracle n'est pas
proposé par l'Église
l'église valide la proposition vrai oui
et le principe d'une canneuse n'importe
quel canalisation de l'éducation c'est
que ça vient en effet du peuple je veux
dire c'est assez reste ça reste un
principe de pratique vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure ça doit venir d'en bas
c'est une paroi c'est un diocèse c'est
une une association de fidèles qui
demande à l'église de juger la vie de
quelqu'un qu'on soumet au jugement de
l'église précédente voilà
écriture sainte oui il y a aussi les
grands poètes grecs nous dit Christian
Léon Toussaint mais effectivement tout
ça fait partie des références avant
dernière question
seigneur Jésus je t'aime ce sont les
derniers mots de rapporter de Benoît XVI
donc dans la nuit du 30 au 31 décembre
avant qu'il ne s'éteignent à 9h34 le 31
décembre dernier Camille est-ce que
c'est chez Benoît xviatinger c'est le
spirituel ou l'intellectuel qui vous
touche le plus
c'est le spirituel parce que parce que
c'est ce que je partage avec lui
qui est croyant et spirituel d'une voilà
et donc c'est vraiment ce qu'on partage
après l'intellectuel c'est ça fait appel
à d'autres
d'autres compétences ou d'autres
appétences donc moi c'est vraiment le
l'aspect spirituel qui est l'homme qui
me l'aspect qui marquera alors on va
peut-être poser la question justement à
deux Français ça va être les dernières
que l'on que l'on va avoir non
effectivement pas tout de suite me dit
al bad BOC qui storiquement
administré coordonne spéciale en
coulisse genre je sais que c'est pas une
question facile que je pose mais vous
allez pouvoir me répondre
si c'est le spirituel ou
l'intellectuelle foyer
j'ai aussi beaucoup d'admiration vous
permettait d'être un peu par exemple il
y a des photos de du cadre Singer qui
boit des chopes de bière comme ça pour
moi ça fait mon grand bonheur
et effectivement on ne
respectera même si sur le web nous ne
sommes pas soumis mais les règles
draconelles en matière de prévention de
l'alcool
Bruno Joubert c'est le spirituel ou
l'intellectuel
je serais tenter de répondre un peu
comme je viens de le faire dans ces vie
avec moi de compétences que lui
notamment sur
l'intellectuel parce qu'il connaît bien
toutes ces questions biologiques mais
moi je pense en effet qu'il a été
en tant que Pape la dimension
spirituelle on la vient d'avoir avec
cette messe très recueillie certainement
été très forte je pense que pour
l'historien
probablement qu'il faudra comme la très
bien dit d'ailleurs de vos intervenants
attendre un petit peu pour mesurer
la densité de ce qui leur a laissé sur
le plan intellectuel et théologique nous
n'en doutons pas à la minute où nous
parlons mais l'histoire nous départagera
probablement vous ça dit de toutes les
dimensions qui vous a le plus touché
c'est ce que vous disiez au début de
l'émission humaine parce que j'ai eu ce
privilège qui est un vrai privilège
d'avoir un entretien avec lui comme vous
l'avez fait et que là pendant ces
minutes c'était d'une intensité et aussi
d'une douceur et d'une incroyable
d'incroyable
ouverture de lui-même il m'a parlé pour
juste donner une idée de la fraternité
définissent qui à l'époque était un
sujet qui est préoccupé il m'a dit des
choses
tellement profonde sur le sentiment
qu'il avait eu que finalement il y avait
en face de lui une très mauvaise volonté
voir une volonté maligne et que ceci le
l'affecté plus que le rendait très très
très très malheureux le Crucifié d'une
certaine façon si je faisais le mot
quand un homme de cette statue vous dit
des choses aussi simplement aussi
durement sur quelque chose comme ça vous
dites cette exceptionnel exceptionnel
petite à partir peut-être sur cette
question c'est un dossier dans lequel il
s'est énormément impliqué en tant que
cardinal et en tant que en tant que Pape
c'est le dossier pour parler vite le
terme est contesté mais le rapport avec
les intégristes et finalement ça a été
un échec ça a été un effet pour lutte
souffrance pour lui je suis pas certain
que les torts soient de son côté
[Rires]
ça c'est autre chose en tout cas il a
tout fait dans un premier temps pour
entre guillemets sauver le soldat
Lefebvre en 88 et et ensuite c'est c'est
pas été pris je pense que c'est une
occasion qui a été manquée par certains
on va retourner à Rome une toute toute
dernière fois puisque Timothée délaime
en partant va trouver deux religieux ce
qui semble être des religieuses
bénédictines et c'est assez rare de les
avoir à l'antenne et donc on va leur
donner la parole
alors Vincent il s'agit de religieuses
dominicaine du Saint-Esprit qui viennent
tout droit de pont Calais en Bretagne
c'est ce que vous me disiez vous avez
appris le décès de buenesse et vous
aussi vous avez pris vos billets pour
venir vous rendre sur la place
Saint-Pierre ce matin oui nous avons
encore décidé de venir à Rome lorsque
nous lui devons beaucoup quand il est
peut-être préfet de Benoît XVI à qui
nous devons tant en tant que Pape en
tant que théologien et c'est vrai que
c'était une cérémonie très très belle
très recueillie beaucoup de prières avec
de la grandeur et de la simplicité comme
il l'avait demandé comme il aimait cette
simplicité c'était tout à l'image de
Benoît XVI qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce
qui vous a marqué qu'est-ce qui vous
marque dans la figure de Benoît XVI
parce que
cette grande simplicité et en même temps
cette
dimension théologique ce qu'avait dit un
cardinal sera au moment de son de
l'élection il avait dit vous verrez il
est intelligent comme dit professeur et
puis comme un premier communion assez un
petit peu ça c'est alliance en lui entre
cette cette immense profondeur
archéologique et cette grande simplicité
on imagine que les autres sœurs de votre
communauté sont restés en France
qu'elles ont suivi cet événement vous
étiez en communion avec elle ce matin
oui on a quelques écoles et les les
sœurs de nos communautés ont suivi
toutes celles qui pouvaient en suivi la
cérémonie avec nos élèves
voilà Vincent pour ces deux religieuses
dominicaines du Saint-Esprit qui ont
donc fait le déplacement pour cette
messe de funérailles de besoins on a on
est passé après de la correctionnelle en
risquant une confusion on a bien dit
juste avant que vous preniez la parole
que c'était des Dominicaines
effectivement même si au début on
pouvait avoir un doute mais ça aussi
c'est pour les initiés alors merci
beaucoup Timothée merci pour ces
témoignages depuis depuis la France
depuis Rome pardon
une dernière question peut-être un
dernier tour de table avec vous
aujourd'hui ce matin merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous
les internautes vous interventions donc
j'en voudrais une dernière qu'est-ce que
vous gardez de cette matinée qu'est-ce
que vous gardez de ces derniers instants
j'en sais rien c'est évidemment le style
ironique était très sobre à l'image du
port de fiscal de Benoît XVI donc ça
recueillement intériorité comme l'a dit
soulier tout à l'heure Jean-Marie
gaynois
moi je voudrais ajouter ça c'est pas par
rapport à cérémonie ce que on a aussi
atterré un des grands derniers témoin de
l'histoire de l'Europe du 20e siècle
puisqu'il a été comme Jean-Paul II sans
son maître en quelque sorte il a vécu
Benoît 16 razziger avec
U le nazisme communisme la guerre froide
le marxisme tous les grands
affrontements sociaux idéologiques
parler de cette Europe phare
intellectuelle c'est pas un enterrement
mais il y a une page qui se tourne et il
sera intéressant de voir si le
successeur n'est pas François d'où
viendra alors moi je suis prêt tout mais
enfin
certains qui a eu un décentrages par
rapport à l'Europe à partir du pont de
François est-ce que ce décentrage va se
maintenir ou pas ça sera la décision des
cardinaux
Camille Lalan verdouti qu'est-ce qui
vous reste de cette matinée et de ces
derniers adieux de bonnes princesses et
bien la simplicité de de cette
célébration
la simplicité aussi de la foule qui
vient mais effectivement pas en grand
nombre mais qui vient quand même et puis
en même temps on voit que c'est un
peuple qui j'étais frappé en rire dans
les images là de la foule de voir que
c'était un peuple qui s'adressait à
toutes les générations et à toutes les à
toutes les toutes les cultures donc
voilà il y a pas besoin de de faire d'en
faire des tonnes pour pour que ça touche
les gens donc voilà c'est ça ce qui m'a
marqué
outre que je partage ce qui a été dit
par mes deux autres les deux autres
intervenants j'ajouterai moi peut-être
une impression d'une quelque chose qui a
été volontairement
restreint
quand on a vu des cérémonies
pontificales
de cette nature ça peut prendre une
ampleur et un et une force beaucoup plus
grande là il y a certainement eu de la
part de ceux qui organisé ça une volonté
justement de coller à l'esprit qui était
celui de Benoît XVI je veux juste un
exemple je peux me tromper j'ai eu
l'impression sur l'écran que par exemple
l'ensemble du corps diplomatique et les
invités qui étaient là n'était pas comme
c'est l'usage en tenue officielle des
décorations avec les jaquettes avec tout
ce qui fait le faste d'une certaine
façon du protocole Vatican mais qu'au
contraire on avait voulu quelque chose
de très normal
Dieu comme intelligent comme un grand
professeur pieux comme un premier
communion c'est ce que nous disait tout
à l'heure cette religieuse comment
professeurs alors je la reprends
intelligent comme dit grands professeurs
pieux comme un premier communion c'est
ce que nous disait donc cette religieuse
merci de m'avoir corrigé pour au sujet
de Benoît XV sans doute c'est ce que
l'on retient ce matin de
cette cérémonie et de la personnalité
qui ressort du pape Benoît XVI on ne se
quitte pas sans avoir sans un peu de
lecture d'abord il faudra que vous
retrouviez très important il est sur le
Figaro Store et il va être en vente dans
les kiosques le hors-série du Figaro
hors série sur le Benoît 16 c'était
Benoît XV c'est un hors-série absolument
à lire qui a été fait au moment de la
renonciation et qui a été réactualisé et
donc
donc par l'équipe du Figaro hors-série
autour de les qualités et de
l'intelligence exceptionnelle de son
chef Michel de Geiger la France
catholique Jean Sévilla c'est chez
Michel Lafont et c'est un nouveau livre
qui est qui mérite vraiment d'être
regardé pour comprendre l'évolution du
catholicisme français dans ces dans dans
depuis quand même une trentaine d'années
donc c'est Jean Sevilla votre prochain
livre
n'en parle pas et votre dernier
le dernier c'était l'histoire de
François sans carte l'histoire de France
en carte effectivement et puis également
on recommande ce le livre sur les
derniers combattants vous avez écrit
avec
Jean-Christophe ils sont que vous êtes
venus nous présenter ici Benoît XVI une
vie c'est la biographie dont on parlait
tout à l'heure avec le père Humbert de
Peter zivald et qui est édité chez Cora
bien entendu tous les livres de Benoît
XVI de Ratzinger sont à lire et
peut-être aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sur la
mort et l'au-delà qui est l'un de ces un
de ses livres un de ses livres majeurs
également et également méconnu merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis merci
d'avoir été avec nous vous avez envoyé
par certains des mots très aimables et
on vous en remercie en tous les cas qui
salutaient la qualité des interventions
sur ce plateau et je ne peux
qu'approuver ce que disait nos
internautes merci beaucoup également
pour vos questions et puis finalement la
tenue qui est revenue dans le chat du
Figaro également sur Youtube merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et merci
également pour vos mots très gentils
merci à tous ceux qui se sont mobilisés
depuis samedi pour cet événement et
merci à ce même qui ont qui ont
contribué qui ont quitté Le Figaro
Charlotte Barillon de nuit et Tristan de
la Thébaudière qui avait interviewé
notamment Jean-Marie guesnoy et
Christophe dicques avant la mort de
Benoît XV pour justement faire déjà un
premier bilan de Spotify merci également
à toutes les équipes donc du Figaro
production et du Figaro live j'en oublie
mais Alban de reine Marie durée du loup
Timothée délai les équipes des réseaux
sociaux avec robinito et à la Régie
autour de Riad Becky et de Sandrine
sodoué et Jean-Marie guesnoy et Timothée
délai à Rome merci beaucoup de nous
avoir
suivi et vous retrouvez bien sûr en
intégralité ce live sur notre page
YouTube et également le replay dans
quelques instants sur le site du Figaro
vous restez avec nous le programme
continue à 17h le buzz 17h30 la question
du jour est 18h point de vue présenter
ce soir par Claudia Cohen à très vite
sur figuer
[Musique]